it was just a job you were meant to be
mopping floors and cleaning toilets at
the Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage and you
were happy about it grateful for any
kind of employment you didn't even know
that the company signing your checks was
the SCP Foundation an organization
dedicated to securing and containing
anomalies and protecting Humanity from
their negative effects at any cost and
today you're going to find out exactly
how steep that cost can be the Johnston
labs and pharmaceuticals Research Center
isn't actually a research center at all
it's a foundation front business with a
building solely dedicated to the
containment of a single anomaly
scp-3280 but again you're just the
janitor it's not like they would bother
telling you what's being contained here
if it breaks out you won't even know
what's killing you until it's too late
it begins like most classic horror
stories on a dark and stormy night
you're mopping up a silent hallway
whistling a little tune to yourself when
rain starts hammering down on the window
next to you not long after you see a
bolt of lightning split the distant Sky
followed by an immense thundercrack soon
after you hear screaming and panicking
From Below frantic footsteps then the
flashing lights and Sirens you think
back to your employee orientation these
flashing lights and wailing Sirens can
only mean one thing Containment Breach
you run for it not even knowing what
you're running from you bring your mop
and bucket with you perhaps just out of
habit you seek refuge in the only place
in the facility that truly seems to
belong to you the broom closet the alarm
blares as you lock yourself in the
closet you're shaking with Terror and
can hear the screaming of your
colleagues you hear more noises running
scrambling a wet dripping sound gunshots
and then silence all this time you can't
help but wonder why isn't anybody coming
to help us after a while the only thing
you can hear is the rain and the distant
Thunder it's been hours you've only
managed to Stave off dehydration by
drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink but at least it seems like the
chaos outside has died down carefully
you open the door and peek out of the
closet Darkness but no detectable
movement now's your chance and you make
a break for it creeping down the hall
the dark hallway is suddenly lit up by
lightning and you can see that there are
bodies everywhere you step over the
corpse of Dr cothrone one of the few
scientists working here who actually
knew your name if you can make it to the
security office you might be able to
radio for help or maybe access a
computer terminal on the way to the
office you hear another horrific screen
start to echo through the complex before
it's cut off by a Thunderclap you have
to ignore it though and push
when you enter the security room you see
that the head security officer Nichols
is already dead his body has been cut
open from neck to groin gutted the
anomaly whatever it is has already been
here you access the computer terminal
and open the file for
scp-3280 you're warned that as
janitorial staff you have level zero
clearance and as a result information
will be omitted from the files you
access it doesn't matter you press on
and open up the file both the object
class and the description have been
redacted you can only see the special
containment procedures they dictate that
3280 is to remain contained at the
Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center until long-term
containment procedures can be drawn up
if the entity ever reaches Beyond
sub-level 2 the facility enters full
lockdown mode not even information is
allowed in or out of the facility as
this could result in an XK Class end of
the world scenario in other words nobody
is coming to save you the only other
information on the page is a picture of
a lightning storm much like the one you
find yourself in right now lightning
flashes in the hall you Dart around
paranoid knowing the anomaly could be
anywhere all you can hear now is the
quiet drip drip drip of blood coming
from the body of security officer
Nichols whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around nickels
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nichols was the kind of
guy who'd write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level 2
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift news attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr
Emmanuel stumbling down a dark Corridor
his movements are oddly listless like
he's in the trance suddenly there's
another flash of lightning and a crack
of thunder Dr Emmanuel clutches his gut
in pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols in the special
containment procedures now their
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from
sub-level 2 and see another corpse lying
in the corner her he's wearing an orange
jumpsuit d-class no idea why he was down
there the only other notable thing in
the basement was a burst pipe leaking
and spraying more water everywhere with
trembling fingers you select the camera
feed for the first floor cafeteria the
whole room is practically under water
the only evidence of the massacre that
must have taken place are the fragments
of clothing floating on the surface of
the water that and the fleshy pink
slurry forming at the bottom of the
windows it reminds you of the gooey meat
runoff in chicken nugget factories you
close your eyes and try to Center
yourself it's violent chaos looking at
more of it isn't getting you anywhere
instead you put those new level 2
security access credentials to good use
and hop back onto the file for
scp-3280 you think to yourself there has
to be something I can use on here but
even as you wait for the file to load
some part of you knows that time is
running out for you perhaps it's the
stress or the fear or the filthy mop
water you drink but you're feeling the
pressure start to mount physically your
stomach is beginning to ache you can see
blurry shapes moving in the corners of
your eyes it's getting harder to focus
your vision and harder still to quiet
the terrified voices in your mind but
you can't get up not without knowing
what is doing this to you the
containment class for scp-3280 is now
Declassified Euclid and once more the
special containment procedures have
altered too they now explain that every
week a new member of d-class personnel
is to be deposited into the entities
layer in sub-level 2 through
Subterranean access point gamma the
d-class or more accurately the
sacrifices are to be told lies about why
exactly they need to descend to the
lowest point in the facility they're
even given a working flashlight and a
defensive night stick to create the
illusion that the foundation and expects
them to ever return from the depths
little do they know they also have a
tiny transmitter sewn into their
jumpsuit this broadcasts a frequency
that will attract an eager scp-3280 to
the d-class's location like a dinner
bell only it can hear the file specifies
that scp-3280 always prefers live prey
well at least that explains the dead
d-class in sub-level 2. you think hoping
that it will somehow overwhelm the
dizziness you're feeling or the nagging
pain in your cut you read on somehow the
file's tone becomes even more severe it
says that failure to maintain the
containment of scp-3280 will not only
trigger a lockdown it will always call
in the intervention of two different
mobile task forces MTF Iota 12 the
silencers and tau-4 also known as water
water everywhere if 12 hours pass from
the point of initial Containment Breach
and the o5 council hasn't been given the
all-clear signal by one of these teams
preparation Begins for an imminent XK
Class end of the world scenario just
reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat end of the world what on Earth is
this creature finally you reach the
description you get to find out what
this horrifying entity actually is but
the last thing you expect is the first
sentence in the file to read
scp-3280 is a Sapient entity composed of
a fluid physically identical to water
capable of traveling roughly two and a
half kilometers per hour it's water it's
literally a living thinking blob of
water as you read on the concerning
details pile up any water that the
anomalous scp-3280 water touches it
integrates it into its own Mass but
anytime water is separated from this
Mass it remains anomalous and continues
to act independently when the creature
was first discovered it was a mere 66
point 4 liters in volume now it's around
2500 the water infected by scp-3280 is
hostile to all humans and not just in a
defensive manner scp-3280 will actively
seek out human prey and when it finds
them it forces its mass into any
available body orifice including the
victim's pores this can happen in such a
subtle manner that you may not even
notice yourself being infiltrated but
below this the file has a list of
symptoms for those experiencing 3280
infiltration loss of motor control
weakening of the micturition reflex
visual hallucinations and abdominal pain
as you read the words your stomach gives
another painful churn almost like
something is moving around inside of you
it's all coming together you read on the
file states that scp-3280 is so
difficult to contain because it exhibits
claustrophobic Tendencies anytime it's
placed inside a container whether
organic or inorganic it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at
over 255 miles per hour if the water is
inside a human it may literally explode
out of them killing them in the process
your jittering eyes turn to the gutted
body of security officer Nichols it all
makes sense now everything is becoming
clear as the pain in your stomach builds
in its intensity the file goes on to say
that if scp-3280 escapes sub-level 2 it
may be impossible to contain again if
3280 ever escaped the site proper it
would indeed cause an XK Class end of
the world scenario to unfold as 3280
merged with our water cycle and
destroyed all of Humanity on a global
scale it would become truly impossible
for anyone to escape you can't read
anymore the pain in your stomach is
unbearable you jerk from your seat and
stumble out into the Hall doubled over
in agony you can feel it pulsing in
there fighting its way out and must have
gotten in through the filthy mop water
you were drinking you didn't even know
it but your fate has been sealed for
hours you've been a dead man walking the
hum of pain builds in your ears and
renders you almost death all you can
hear is the pattern of rain and distant
Thunder you collapse against the glass
feeling the coolness of it against the
skin of your face and in that moment you
see the water droplets on the window
pane reverse Direction they're
slithering up the glass towards your
face in defiance of gravity then you
realize it's all over and not just for
you
scp-3280 has escaped it's out there and
it's going to drown the entire world as
you collapse to your knees and prepare
to be torn apart from the inside your
final thought is that at least you won't
be alive to see it Jack was swimming
deep underwater wondering why he had
such a pounding headache when suddenly
he had a terrifying realization he had
no idea where he was or what he was
doing there was a nagging feeling that
he must have a specific reason to be
here you don't just end up deep in the
ocean with a diving suit on by chance
yet he had no idea what he was supposed
to be doing he wasn't sure he cared
either he was more worried about the
throbbing pain in his head and the
vision of two eyes staring at him out of
the dark that he couldn't get out of his
mind his heart began to race as he
wondered what to do and how to get help
he was in the middle of the ocean and
appeared to be all alone he couldn't see
anything in the Dark Water except for
this weird gray substance in front of
him maybe he was gonna die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud about
how he was consumed by sickness and that
Darkness was all around him this is the
story of one of the most powerful and
dangerous anomalies yet discovered
scp-3000 before Jack's descent into
despair the SCP Foundation had mandated
an exploratory Expedition off the coast
of Bangladesh after receiving a few
strange reports from locals and
fishermen the Foundation suspected an
SCP was lurking in the water and
positioned a few Personnel to
investigate the crew expected danger or
maybe even death but what they got
instead was Far stranger and more
ominous all of the men had been verified
to be in sound mental States when the
mission set out but a few of them
reported feeling strange and uneasy as
the submarine descended into the ocean
before long a veteran agent named Dr
Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calmed crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand every time he looked at his
colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he'd looked more confused than ever
still the team went deeper Dr Williams
began to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as scp-3000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with the head as big as
a town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
fell to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterward the image of the
eel-like creature's eyes seemed burned
in their minds permanently it would
haunt their waking hours for the rest of
their lives and sleep was no Escape
either as they would appear in both
their dreams and nightmares alike
forever a second mission had to be sent
to gather more information about out the
strange Beast already there were many
theories and question marks surrounding
scp-3000 how big was it really was it
sentient what was the liquid for none of
the men who had been on the previous
Mission were willing to return to the
waters but a new group of Brave recruits
volunteered they were about to find out
what so many in history have learned the
hard way that bravery and foolishness
are often mistaken for the same thing
this time the mission would not be in a
submarine but in dive suits in order to
observe the anomaly in even closer
detail and to eliminate the chance of
one team member self-sabotaging the
submarine killing them all they were
transported to the location by boat and
the three men splashed into the ocean
they descended and at first everything
was going well in case anything went
wrong the three of them were tethered
together for extra security but the
deeper into the ocean they swam and the
closer they got to scp-3000's location
they got the stranger things became just
like on the last mission first there
were a few minor cases of confusion one
of the team Jack thought it was his
responsibility to lead the navigation
education but another Roberto also
thought it was his job in fact
navigation was actually the job of a
third team member Amir but he seemed to
have forgot everyone was getting
confused the team listening in on the
conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away two years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that was holding them together all alone
Jack couldn't remember where he was or
why he was here he does desperately
looked around to try and gauge his
surroundings but he could only see
Darkness all he could think about was a
pair of large eyes and an overwhelming
fear of Despair and anxiety and this
weird gray fluid that was now floating
in front of him the foundation listened
as Jack started reciting a creepy speech
about being on the edge of nothing
inches from Oblivion with a sickness in
his mind and nothing but a pair of eyes
in front of him they listened in horror
as they heard movement through the radio
it sounded like a huge creature was
swimming toward the men it had to be
scp-3000 but all three men were too
confused to do anything about the
situation or to even see what was in
front of him claiming they couldn't see
anything in the darkness there was
silence for half a minute with the team
listening in fearing the worst then they
heard some more unintelligible
mutterings the men must be alive but
what on Earth was going on then the
gibberish started again two of the men
were screaming that Jack had just been
swallowed whole and that they were being
sucked in too why couldn't they just
swim away it was chaos but then a few
moments later Roberto spoke into the
radio saying he was floating alone in
the middle of the ocean and had now
moved away from the eyes of scp-3000 he
finally seemed capable of forming
coherent thoughts and speech after what
had just happened Roberto now had a
theory he thought that somehow it was
impossible to think straight around
scp-3000 when he'd been close enough to
see the eyes Roberto had felt a
throbbing pain in his brain and been
unable to think about anything perhaps
it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of scp-3000 now and
Roberta was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later git acquired some very important
data but he seemed to have lost all hope
of preserving his life Roberto started
telling the team over the radio that he
was dying and that his heart rate was
too high but cautioned that it would be
too dangerous for anyone to try and
rescue him the Personnel continued to
try and communicate with Roberto to
figure out what was going on but his War
words that stopped making any sense
until finally he went quiet minutes
turned into hours hours into days and
still there was no sign of Roberto or
the rest of the divers after three days
His Radio which had only been sending a
steady stream of Static finally stopped
working altogether and he was presumed
dead however the sample Roberto had
collected had survived and made it to
the hands of the foundation researchers
it turned out to be a viscous substance
now known as y-909 a chemical compound
an extremely strong anesthesia why 909
causes head pain paranoia fear Panic
memory loss and confusion explaining
what happened to Dr Williams in the
diving Trio the collection of y-909
might have resulted in two disastrous
missions but there's a silver lining as
the substance ended up becoming an
invaluable tool for the SCP Foundation
its ability to make people forget what
had just happened to them can be used to
eliminate knowledge of threatening scps
among the public it also helps the
foundation staff cope with the traumatic
experiences they encounter on their
missions although other amnesia 6 can be
used for the same purpose none are as
powerful as the one produced by scp-3000
before its Discovery the amnestics used
would break down too quickly not
farewell in storage or cause undesirable
side effects the only problem is the
method of sourcing the only way to
obtain why 909 is somewhat ethically
questionable for most people
scp-3000 produces y-909 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
humanity now the foundation protects
scp-3000 as best as it can guard
something hundreds of kilometers long
the area is carefully patrolled and
members of the public are not allowed to
enter the part of the bay where it
resides anybody who accidentally comes
into contact is contained eventually
another pair of foundation doctors went
down in the submarine to try and learn
more about scp-3000 one became so
affected by why 909 that he began
hallucinating he started talking about
ananta shesha the king of serpents in
Hinduism and not the shesha is believed
to be all that will be left after the
end of the world because it exists
throughout all of time simultaneously
the doctor said he believed that this
was in fact ananta shesha that scp-3000
simply shows us that eventually everyone
dies and Fades into the darkness of
Oblivion right before he exited the
submarine and swam right into his mouth
luckily for now scp-3000 seems to be in
a sort of hibernation state it rarely
moves and it doesn't hunt although it
will eat when fed but no one knows when
or if it'll wake or what it's capable of
if it does will it destroy the world or
simply drive us all insane Commander
McGrath one of the most influential
members of mobile task force alpha 1
better known as the red right hand had
been summoned by his Masters for one of
the most important missions of his life
it was so Above Top Secret even he would
likely need to undergo amnesic treatment
once he'd seen the job through it comes
with the territory when you're dealing
with
scp-006 the red right hand is no
ordinary mobile task force either they
were the personal enforcers of the o5
council the 13 most powerful members of
the SCP Foundation and by extension some
of the most powerful human beings on
Earth Commander McGrath stood before the
assembled Council trying to suppress the
Tremors of fear and awe running through
him he'd gone toe-to-toe with scp-076
Abel one of the finest humanoid Warriors
ever known during one of his many
containment breaches he led strike
forces after a fleeing
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
after it escaped its acid tank and began
charging towards the nearest populated
area intent on causing Mass death he'd
personally taken out more people than
you've probably ever met all at the
behest of his found nation's superiors
and yet standing right here before them
he couldn't help feel a twinge of deep
Terror it was like staring right into
the face of God and waiting for it to
Blink with his well-honed military
observation skills he noted that 05-2
wasn't among the council this time but
he knew better than to ask why he was
employed to take orders not to ask
questions and this time his orders were
something special he wasn't given any
more information than this McGrath we
need you to lead an elite team to
Australian and Russia on the double
procedure006 is now in effect you know
what to do McGrath nodded he'd been
prepared for this day his predecessor
Commander Richards had only needed to
enact procedure 006 once in his long and
storied career with the red right hand
it was truly a once in a lifetime
assignment and now the torch had been
passed to him the only question was
whether he'd be up to the town
but McGrath didn't have time to ponder
on this question time was of the essence
first he needed to assemble a team small
but focused loyal men who'd Keep Their
Heads down complete the mission and take
the Forbidden Knowledge no further than
the bounds of said Mission McGrath
selected three operatives Bennett
DiMaggio and Stewart all of whom had
proven valuable assets in Prior missions
they would be the ones to accompany him
on this most valuable and secretive of
directives
procedure006 but before they could
execute the mission itself they needed
to be trained briefed and fitted with
the proper equipment for Mission this
sensitive and dealing with an anomaly as
deadly as
scp-006 they needed to wear modified
class 6 BNC suits these are the ultimate
total exclusion hazmat suits designed
specifically by the SCP Foundation they
offered such a degree of protection that
they made Regular hazmat suits look like
bikini Commander McGrath actually knew
very little about
scp-006 and how it worked like many of
the more top secret anomalies contained
by the foundation only the o5 council
understood the full scope of it everyone
below them were only told the specific
fragments of information they needed to
do their job after all filling your head
with the wrong kinds of knowledge can
get your memory wiped or worse at the
SCP Foundation
scp-006 as far as Commander McGrath knew
was the more traditional kind of toxic
he'd been briefed using the
scp-006-b info pack a heavily redacted
description of
scp-006 safe class liquid in nature but
one of the most toxic substances known
to man it made Mercury and uranium look
like a glass of mineral water and more
dangerous still if someone came into
contact with even the tiniest quantity
of
scp-006's liquids they would not only be
marked for certain death then a would
also become a vector for transmission a
veritable plague rat a walking danger to
all mankind that's why the class 6 BNC
suits needed to be tested McGrath
Bennett DiMaggio and Stewart suited up
in a secure foundation training facility
and fully submerged themselves in a
training pool this was how they made
sure that there were no vulnerabilities
in the suits if any bubbles were
generated it meant there was a leak and
if there was a leak then the person
wearing the defective suit was as good
as dead when they reached the real zero
zero six lucky for them no leaks they
were ready to proceed to the next stage
of the mission making their way to
astrachan Russia where scp-006 was
contained the pressure was on with the
council growing more impatient by the
moment so they needed to make the
journey immediately every minute counted
and Commander McGrath was painfully
aware of the time slipping away though
he couldn't pass possibly fathom why
they need a toxic chemical like this
with such urgency they made their
journey in a covert cargo plane it was
beyond important to keep all Foundation
activity around
scp-006 Under Wraps a number of groups
of Interest cells were active in the
area including the Church of the broken
God and the Serpent's hand and if ever
the dreaded chaos Insurgency caught wind
of
scp-006's existence and triangulated its
location the damage it could do would be
unprecedented that's why nobody but the
o5 council could truly be trusted with
this almost sacred knowledge when they
touched down in the Strachan they met
with a foundation Courier who would take
them on the final leg of their Journey
to the foundation site roughly 60
kilometers west of the Town McGrath and
his team had no idea what they were
headed towards or the insane history of
the land they traversed all because of
scp-006 the foundation had first become
aware of the anomaly back during the
19th century but were unable to gain
control of it until 1991. due to it
being fiercely guarded by A procession
of territorial Russian rulers the blood
of hundreds of thousands had been
spilled on this land in the historic
Wars and conflicts over
scp-006 so many had wasted their entire
lives unsuccessfully trying to find it
during the several hour car trip to the
site Commander McGrath had no idea of
the true value of the anomaly he and his
small team were heading towards but he
would in time though an innocent would
have to die first The Courier dropped
the four operatives off outside an
abandoned chemical plant in the sticks
far from what anyone would call
civilization it was the kind of
industrial Decay you could expect in the
Badlands of rural Russia a huge complex
weathered and broken by time but what
the untrained Observer wouldn't realize
is that the plant was actually full of
heavily trained and even more heavily
armed Foundation security personnel has
McGrath's team approached the building
they had no less than eight sniper
rifles pointed at them from various
Vantage points within the plant just to
be safe the foundation couldn't afford
to take any chances with
scp-006 they arrived at the gate and
provided their clearance credentials
they were envoys here on behalf of the
o5 council themselves and if they
weren't allowed to complete their
mission then the 006 Personnel would
have the death of a council member on
their hands with that the team was given
a free pass into the site under close
observation anyone seeking to interface
as cp006 was forced to do so under
almost microscopic scrutiny even when
inside the building McGrath and his men
needed to pass multiple secure
checkpoints throughout the Halls each
time restating their security
credentials eventually they reached a
different section of the building
foreboding anomalous hallways gave way
to what seemed like a mix of a garden
and a jungle but the plants were
different the trees the shrubs even the
weeds were unlike anything members of
the team had ever seen before it was
like stepping into an alien world or
perhaps this world but as it was a few
million years prior it was terrifying
and wondrous they suited up in their
class 6 BNC suits fearing Airborne
contaminants from scp-006 before
proceeding further they walked through
this new Jungle being watched at every
turn by security cameras and Personnel
posted throughout this overgrown portion
of the facility it didn't take long for
them to reach their destination the
legendary
scp-006 a small natural spring jutting
out of a rock surrounded by Rich Emerald
grass it looked more like a nice place
to have a picnic than a dangerous and
highly secretive anomaly but McGrath
wasn't paid to question things only to
carry out procedures 0.006 the only
object they had with them was the quad
sealant container an ultra secure liquid
containment unit specifically designed
for safely transporting samples of
scp-006's water between sites the team
members descended into the spring and
began filling up the container it was
nerve-wracking knowing the stakes of
their mission and knowing that they were
submerged in such a deadly substance but
they had a job to do and they were going
to do it come hell or high water they
filled the containment unit but sadly
for McGrath and his team the mission
wouldn't be entirely without casualty a
single bubble Rose from the leg of
Stewart's suit he was a good MTF
operative but the youngest and least
experienced member of the team his suit
must have somehow been damaged during
Transit and now he was compromised he
shared a haunting glance with McGrath
and his fellow team members knowing that
his part of the mission and his life was
about to come to a Swift and violent and
alarms rang out across the facility a
huge team of armed operatives all
wearing class 6 BNC suits charged into
the room Steward was grabbed and
manhandled out of the zero zero six
spring while his fellow team members
sealed the containment unit and
continued their mission there was no
time to stop rest or mourn completing
the mission was the absolute priority if
McGrath understood the protocol as well
as he thought he did Stewart would be
dragged into a secure room by the site's
staff and locked in with a blast door he
would look down and notice the floor
below him was a metal grate caked with
Ash his last thoughts as the incinerator
launches its Flames into action would
strangely be the fact that he was
feeling the healthiest he'd been in
years but that wouldn't stop the sudden
furnace around him from decimating his
body and leaving little more than Ash
and Shard bones over a decade of loyal
MTF service ended in an instant Stewart
would have been terminated according to
orders from the top it was all that
could be done for those afflicted by a
cp006 a mercy really if they were to be
believed McGrath and his team soldiered
on after retrieving the sample they were
hurried back into their Inception point
one of the many classified bases
occupied by the o5 council members while
DiMaggio and Bennett were ushered off to
be given themnestic treatment McGrath
would personally get to see the
containment unit and its Precious Cargo
make the final leg of the journey he was
going to be granted access
205-2 the person this had all been in
service of Commander McGrath approached
the secure quarters of the council
member escorted by a bevy of heavily
armed security Personnel the doors
opened and he saw her there
05-2 bedridden laying at the center of a
grand web of life-saving Technology she
was beyond old and decrepit Commander
McGrath could see the century she'd
endured written deeply in the wrinkles
and scars of her ancient face she didn't
look like one of the most powerful
people in the world she looked like one
of the most feeble her eyes lit up when
McGrath entered the room holding the
containment unit she beckoned him closer
until he was close enough for her to
take the containment unit from him with
scarred Trembling Hands McGrath watched
in horror as she disengaged the lid and
swigged down the entirety of its
contents but wasn't the water toxic he
thought McGrath had been fed the same
lie as everybody else the foundation
didn't keep 006 such a well-guarded
secret because it was capable of
bringing death quite the opposite in
fact all Commander McGrath could do was
stare awestruck as the years seemed to
fall from 05-2's face decades and
decades and decades scars faded wrinkles
disappeared little by little 05-2 began
to sit and then stand by the time she
was straightening her clothes she looked
like a healthy woman in her mid-40s it
was a complete and total transformation
the liquid of s cp006 has a plethora of
benefits to human subjects the ability
to regenerate damage DNA by heightened
excitement of cellular duplication and
producing a frightening increase in the
effectiveness of the human immune system
even upon testing the liquid on animal
subjects hostile bacteria and viral
agents were destroyed immediately
members of the o5 council are experts at
cheating death and scp-006 is just
another Ace hidden up their sleeve in
the endless battle against the reaper a
secret so well guarded that they're
willing to terminate even their most
loyal servants to keep it safe after all
if everyone knew about it everyone would
want it and the o5 council are very
invested in exclusivity never normally
one to rise above his station Commander
McGrath couldn't help blurt out but if
it was a lie private Stewart is
perfectly alive all smoke and mirrors
you see and like everyone who works a006
Mission he won't remember a thing good
work Commander McGrath 05-2 now in
perfect health replied now return to
your post after a visit to our boys and
amnestics there's still plenty to be
done and we can't afford to dilly dally
after all you're not getting any younger
40 years ago a U.S Navy exploratory
vessel landed on a chain of islands in
the South Atlantic just 2 000 miles off
the coast of Argentina in other words
the middle of nowhere yet on this
far-off set of rocks afloat in the
middle of the ocean they discovered a
vast array of strange wildlife and plant
species that resemble little of what
they left behind on the mainland could
this be a treasure Trove of undiscovered
species they wondered hoping to
capitalize on the Discovery a
reconnaissance team of researchers was
sent out to explore some of the islands
on foot and what they found did not
disappoint from endangered species of
birds to plant life and vegetation that
looked like it belonged on Mars they
found a dizzying array of new and
exciting examples of evolutionary
Oddities that would fill a library but
unfortunately their Jubilation was cut
short attempting to collect soil samples
they dug into the ground and soon
discovered that what they were standing
on wasn't actually ground at all the
Navy scientists soon discovered the
rocky terrain they were exploring was
actually made up entirely of organic
matter as per the standard protocol the
SC Foundation was forced to silence the
U.S Navy research vessel after its
Discovery with the OK from the U.S
government the ship was torpedo and sunk
to the bottom of the ocean with all
hands on deck in the name of protecting
the greater good of the masses a tragedy
at sea for the sake of preventing
worldwide pandemonium from there the
foundation took over with the
containment procedures of what would
eventually come to be known as
scp-169 better known by its nickname the
Leviathan The Leviathan is a Biblical
creature of mythical proportions said to
be able to boil the Seas and create
earth-ending floods with just a whip of
its massive continent spanning body it
is unclear if scp-169 has the ability to
do these things though given its massive
size which Foundation researchers
estimate to be somewhere between 2000
and 8 000 kilometers it's easy to see
how something that big moving at any
speed could be devastating for the
coastal regions of the world although we
use the word contain it is impossible
for SCP staff to ever contain something
of such massive size surveillance and
monitoring are about all we can do for
now that and hope it never wakes up and
decides that we're on the menu it was
thought to be relatively smooth sailing
until one incident changed everything Dr
Hart turned off the video monitor and
faced the assembled members of MTF
gamma-6 also known as the Deep feeders
renowned for their specialization in the
tracking of deep sea and oceanic
anomalies the room was dark and each
team member was sitting in Shadow but
still Dr Hart could see the seriousness
on their faces I'm sure you're wondering
why I called you here at such short
notice he said on the screen behind him
he put up a NASA satellite picture of a
small set of Rocky Islands you see this
little island chain here well it wasn't
there a week ago he paused rubbing his
forehead from lack of sleep at 805 am
today we recorded another auditory
anomaly emitting from
scp-169 this one was much louder and
longer than the one recorded in 1997 by
the National Oceanic and Atmospheric
Administration the one known as the
bloop back then it was easy to brush off
as some ice breaking off of a
continental shelf and scraping against
the seafloor it's not so easy to cover
up anymore these auditory emissions from
scp-169 are beginning to grow more
frequent more than that increased
seismic activity around the archipelago
on the creature's back indicates that
the rate at which the creature is
breathing is also up typically the rate
at which the creature takes what we are
assuming to be a breath is once every
three months the rate has increased to
once every three weeks for as long as
we've been monitoring scp-169 it's been
a drift along the southern Atlantic
never moving more than a kilometer a
week that behavior is slowly beginning
to change it doesn't sound like much but
something that big even moving just a
fraction of that faster means 100 foot
tidal waves for the entire South
American Coastline We Fear the creatures
showing signs of waking up if this is
true it could mean a cataclysm for the
hundreds of Nations around the world
Millions hell even billions could be
wiped off the face of the Earth if this
thing just flips its body too fast in
the wrong direction to put it to scale
this monster is about the size of the
Caribbean maybe even bigger as far as we
know the doctor then pulled out a
decanter of whiskey and poured himself a
glass swallowing the entire core in one
go in an appalling breach of workplace
professionalism seriously an XK Class
end of the world scenario is still no
excuse for drinking on the job we're
talking about an extinction level event
a bona fide XK Class end of the world
scenario one thousand foot tsunami wave
stretching as far as the eye can see
from either end of The Horizon the last
time scp-169 started created the media
three in fact the legends of the
biblical flood Noah's Ark the same story
can be found in every civilization and
culture around the world so maybe they
were on to something it is to this end I
call you all here save the world from
the next great flood he paused for a
moment as the room took in the gravity
of the situation the more we can learn
about
scp-169 the better and right now we know
SWAT for one we've never seen just how
deep the body of the creature goes or
what's under it the pressure has been
too great for our current model
submarines until now after reinforcing
our Nemo one deep sea submersible with
thematurtical runes the Integrity of its
Hull has increased exponentially your
mission will be to travel as far down
and as close to the creature as possible
if it breathes then there must be gills
or lungs there must be some basic
biological facts we need to understand
if we're going to survive extinction our
only recourse is to find a way to sedate
the creature and if that doesn't work
um
God help us all just 12 hours later deep
in the waters of the Southern Atlantic a
massive submersible ship was diving down
into the depths of the deep ocean
looking for a way to stop the end of the
world agent Jaws 6-1 a member of deep
feeders looked out of the massive
viewing Port as the ship slowly
descended alongside the rocky trench
that made up the body of
scp-169 behind him was Dr Hart sporting
a white five o'clock shadow and a red
nose from a night of drinking to calm
his nerves the entire crew were silent
in awe as the giant floodlights of the
ship brushed over the barnacle-covered
surfaces of the undersea mountain they
progressed slowly reaching each
milestone in depth with caution knowing
that one wrong move could destabilize
the pressure in their ship just 6-1
murmured the word scales what as Dr Hart
I've been watching the patterns of The
Ridges as we sink down they look like
scales giant segments it's hard to see
at first because they're so covered in
Barnacles and sediment but I'm sure of
it the giant armored scales the way
lobsters or crabs have armored
exoskeletons interesting the doctor said
scratching his chin arthropods have
segmented armored bodies this means we
might be looking at some sort of
evolutionary hybrid some sort of aquatic
mammal such as a whale or dolphin the
one that has developed armored segment
in Scales similar to that of a
crustacean the doctor crossed his arms
to think the closest thing we have on
the fossil record of this magnet is an
armored fish from the Cretaceous Period
but even that way too small to compare
to this this thing has an entire
ecosystem on its back how old is it ask
the agent well now that you mention it
given the impossible age of the creature
an arthropod would make sense lobsters
and other Crustaceans don't age
conventionally you see they are
effectively Immortal in fact they
actually die because they continue to
grow until their bodies can't hold up
their humongous size anymore
scp-169 just kept growing the doctor
trailed off thinking to himself Dr Hart
still lost in thought turned to walk to
the back of the submersible as just 6-1
followed he said as much to himself as
to the agent the creature is old the
Geological Survey conducted when scp-169
was first discovered coven dated the
specimen to over 541 million years old
as we can probably surmise that's too
old for any living being the results had
to be incorrect and yet I checked them
myself more than once and numbers do not
lie The Entity predates our civilization
hell it predates complex life forms on
this planet as we know it from an
evolutionary standpoint it doesn't make
any sense the agent confused asked
doctor how could something so big even
come into existence very little of our
planet is actually land mass it's a
wonder we call it Earth most of this
planet is water we aren't looking at a
creature that's on our planet agent we
are on its Planet just in a flurry of
alarms and sensors began to go off at
the bridge of the ship the team
scrambled through their stations
checking off monitors and shouting
readings to each other the ship's
thermal sensors are detecting a massive
rise in temperature transmitting power
to cooling systems we have activity
Northwest of our location sonar has
something big headed our way we need to
dive now the ship lurched forward knows
first as everyone on board held onto
their seats the restraints keeping them
from falling forward just outside of the
view on the port Dr Hart could see an
enormous scale the pendage moving fast
in their location we need to steer the
ship clear of the talons revert all
power to the thrusters get us out of the
way Dr yell don't you think I'm doing
that the captain shut it back the ship
jolted sideways and downwards as an
immense wave of pressure came over the
submersible putting six G's of force on
its occupants just 6-1 yelped out of
fear as the ship came close to crashing
into what appeared to be the edge of a
Titanic Talon the size of the Empire
State Building following the encounter
the part of the ship bordering the
reinforced glass of the viewing Port
began to Glow bright red it's boiling
the water around us one of the crew
members cried out it's not boiling
anything it's just cavitation due to the
pressure reduction in the water the
updated runes on the ship's Hall should
keep us safe we just need to cool our
heads stay focused on the mission Bottom
Feeders after several moments of holding
their breaths the crew of Nema 1 began
to relax as their Pace returned to a
slow descent along the side of the
underwater Behemoth before long The
Vessel was no longer traveling straight
down but starting to curve under the
creature traveling north towards the
theoretical head of
scp-169 after several hours the ship
Came Upon giant fissures in the Rocky
exterior of the creature these massive
vent-like structures appeared stiff but
slowly they opened and closed over the
span of weeks these were the respiratory
organs of the organism blocking it in
over two miles underneath the surface of
the ocean the crew carefully began
entering the smaller pod-like
submersibles that detached from their
main ship just 6-1 entered his pod and
strapped on the haptic gloves that would
give him control of the pod's robotic
arms he and a team of three other
volunteers had agreed to undergo The
Dangerous Mission of attaching
artificial chemical emission machines
that could be programmed to release
anesthetic gas into
scp-169's respiratory system on command
remotely the emission machines could be
refueled manually whenever the contents
ran out it was an ingenious solution Dr
Hart came up with when thinking of his
time studying sharks as a Marine
they were tag the fins of sharks by
capturing them and bringing the
specimens on the deck of their boat from
there the scientists would drill a radio
frequency emitter onto the fin of the
shark when he had first seen this
practice as a young college student Dr
Hart was afraid the process was harming
the shark but later he learned it was
designed in a way to not be harmful to
the specimen and eventually the tag
would fall off after enough data on the
shark's movement was collected except
these tags would not be falling off he
thought they could not for the sake of
all mankind this had to work the doctor
pressed a button on the receiver of the
radio and spoke just 6-1 what's your
status pressure's holding all signs look
good just 6-2 precious holding all good
Joe 6-3 all clear Captain Joe 6-4 there
was silence just successful do you copy
all clear doc sorry my mic was muted on
Route and ready to do this thing Dr
Hart's side and relief and slowly
reclined in his chair watching the pods
move closer to the large openings on
scp-169 side one by one the robotic arms
used underwater torches to drill into
the thick rock-like exoskeleton of the
creature screwing in complex million
dollar equipment that was both
waterproof and could withstand the
immense pressure at such a depth under
the ocean as the minutes turned to hours
Dr Hart couldn't help but feel anxiety
for the safety of his crew and the
success of the mission but before long
the pods began to return one by one to
the mothercraft each completing the
segment of work with which they were
tasked the last pod still working was
just 6-1 whose robotic arm was in the
process of rotating a large industrial
size screw just 6-1 had all but finished
when suddenly a low Rumble could be felt
shaking the larger submersible Dr Hart's
voice came crackling over the radio get
back to the ship now just 6-1 wrapped in
deep focus on his task replied I'm just
about finished just packing up my tool
belt leave it return onto the ship now
that's an order Jesus what's wrong it's
not like this is the end of the world
said the agent chuckling over his radio
an ear piercing Echo sent shock waves
through the depths of the ocean around
the submersible the waves rumbled with
the sound of
scp-169's voice similar to the sound of
a large whale but Amplified by a million
the sound sent all the crew members
falling to the floor as the ship
experienced severe damage from the burst
of pressure slightly cracking the glass
viewport and sending smoke flooding into
the small Bridge of the ship gas masks
shouted Dr Hart as they all dawned
breathing apparatus scp-169 is waking up
begin activation of the chemical
emission machines we need to sedate it
now the Leviathan is waking up we need
to stop it shouted Dr Hart just then he
looked back and noticed just 6-1's pod
was gone Joe 6-1 what's your position
just 6-1 where are you sarasana has him
drifting off deep into the ocean behind
us he must have gotten knocked off as
cp16 69 by the Shockwave but Dr Hart
would inhabit he didn't want any more
blood on his hands reverse thrusters
turn us around and get to him we're not
losing anyone but the breach in the hull
it'll hold that's what the ruins are for
the outside of the summer spell began to
Glow a slight blue as the ship's system
started to come back online to full
capacity and alarm system started to
turn off and Report normal pressure
readings before long the Nemo one had
caught up to just 6-1's pod and
retrieved the agent with the knocked
unconscious by the Shockwave once the
agent was back on the main ship the
doctor turned his attention back to the
monitors making sure the installations
they drilled into the creature were
functional slowly the machines came
online to full power and the speed at
which scp-169 had been moving began to
slow ever so slightly the team all
watched the viewport in silence as a
steady stream of anesthetic gas was
pumped into the respiratory system of
the gigantic living myth in front of
them after a few moments of waiting the
doctors spell I think it worked he said
with a smile the crew erupted in cheers
as they radioed control back up on land
that the mission had been a success the
message quickly reached the o5 council
where a red alert status was
de-escalated and the o5 members withdrew
from their plan of leaving the current
Earth for that of an alternate universe
the whole crew began to sing and
celebrate the prevention of the end of
the world as Dr Hart simply stood in
front of the massive viewport watching
the mountainous specimen slowly grow
smaller in the distance as the
submersible began ascending back to the
world above just 6-1 came over to
congratulate him patting him on the back
we did it he said loosen up the doctor
managed to laugh along in acknowledgment
but we did he said relief that we did
the two watched the deep blue ocean in
silence taking in the vastness of the
sea perhaps this would not be the end of
it but that day they had done what the
SCP Foundation did best kick that
apocalyptic can a few miles down the
road and sometimes in the face of the
terrifying and the infinite that's
really the best you can do your rights
in the middle of one of the hottest
Summers on record the days are filled
with bright scorching sun and Searing
heat and you've been laying around with
your air conditioning on full blast just
to try and cool yourself off sadly it's
not really working and the heat is
becoming way too much but then you
remember there's this married couple
that lives near you with no kids and
they happen to have a swimming pool in
their yard normally they keep to
themselves they'd never let you use
their pool but they've gone out of town
for a few days besides the is killing
you you're sure that the neighbors
wouldn't mind if you just took a quick
dip as long as you clean up after
yourself they probably wouldn't even
notice you were even there cautiously
you make your way to their house it's an
unremarkable Place similar to most of
the other houses in this suburb of New
Mexico after checking that there's
nobody else around you climb the two
meter high cinder block wall that stands
around the back Garden as you drop to
your feet sweaty and panting from the
unrelenting summer heat you see it the
pool your salvation water never looks so
appealing immediately you step Barefoot
across the Sun scorched tiles and sit on
the edge legs in the water it's cool and
refreshing perfect for a day is hot as
today you already changed in wearing
your swim trunks so it doesn't take long
for you to paddle out to the middle of
the pool letting that chilled clean
water cool you off as you're taking a
dip you notice the pool's Jets turning
on automatically it's a little bit odd
but you shrug it off that couple clearly
shelled out for a pool with a lot of
fancy bells and whistles but extra
features aren't why you're here you came
because if you didn't then you could
have melted under all that sunlight
floating on the surface of the water you
relax with your arms behind your head
and close your eyes you don't have time
to realize that coming here was a
mistake instead you start to feel
relaxed so calm so tranquil you're one
with the water around you now it's
almost as though you could just
disappear so you do the police never
find any trace of you everyone else
simply writes it off as a random
disappearance there's not even so much
as a scrap of your body left in the pool
just the clear clean water why because
the swimming pool you decided to take a
cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary pool
it was
scp-242 but but don't worry you won't be
the last to make that costly mistake
what you didn't know is that the married
couple who live in that house are
secretly a pair of SCP Foundation
doctors the house isn't even theirs the
foundation procured it after the former
owner her retired out-of-state landlord
strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after three days he was
never seen again now that house has only
one rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim in the pool
scp-242 is at least to the untrained eye
just an average swimming pool a decent 9
meters in length four and a half wide
and it holds around 53 000 liters of
sterile pool water like we mentioned
before it's even got some Nifty features
like water jets a dual waterfall and a
built-in vacuum unit for sucking out any
impurity
and we mean any impurities you see
scp-242 does go by another name the
self-cleaning pool and while that might
not sound as foreboding or dramatic as
the Scarlet king or the wendigo skull or
the horrifying nasty dude of ultimate
Badness okay we made that last one up we
can assure you that you don't ever want
to suffer the fate of taking a swim in
this pool there was an incident a while
ago recorded by the foundation through a
secret hidden camera the house where
scp-242 can be found had been left
vacant for a time and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage
of the empty swimming pool this time it
was a couple a man and a woman in their
early 20s they climbed up the back wall
undressed and even stole a couple of
plastic inflatable rafts from a shed in
The house's backyard the water jets
switched themselves on startling the
girl but her boyfriend told her not to
worry the filter to clean the pool was
probably just on an automatic timer
right surely it wouldn't have been
anything to worry about after swimming
together for around 24 minutes the
couple both agreed that the water felt
warm tingly even both of them climbed
onto their rafts eventually falling
asleep while still holding each other's
hands but almost half an hour after the
Jets had started something caused the
two rafts to burst the couple awoke
startled by the loud pop of the
splitting Inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
in fear and Agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the woman were Pulled Under the
surface of the Raging Water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the Crimson bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red in the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clearer after 48 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the Press by the SCP
Foundation two weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had
elope together somewhere in Mexico if
only that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does scp-242 work is it an
interdimensional Gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh-eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds well
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of these it's unclear what
causes the pool's anomalous effects it
could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in scp-242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in
scp-242 it will be entirely Rewritten on
a molecular level the genetic anatomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water that remains sterile even when
removed from the pool if you took a cup
of scp-242's water and mix something
like food coloring into it the food
coloring would not be absorbed into the
water instead staying as one
non-missable bubble this process doesn't
happen instantly though it can vary
depending on how contaminated or complex
the substance placed in scp-2 242 is for
example water sampled from a nearby
River was sterilized and purified by the
pool in about seven minutes a sample of
stagnant pond water riddled with various
diseases and germs took 11 minutes
longer what about 50 000 liters of coal
tar well that one took a little longer
12 long days to be exact but was still
turned into pure sterile water and as
for a living human being maybe ask that
couple that took a dip in the
self-cleaning pool the foundation is
naturally fascinated with the pool and
after extensive examination they have
determined that scp-242 doesn't seem to
have been intentionally designed for the
specific anomalous function it performs
the components of scp-242 beyond the
pool itself the filter the vacuum the
pipes none of these parts nor anything
about the swimming pools design appear
to be responsible for disintegrating
matter until only water remains you
might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in
scp-242 the water jets and waterfall
features switched themselves on
automatically before the pair's Grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
Jets and waterfall from coming on once a
non-water substance is placed into
scp-242 the same goes for the pool
vacuum which apparently cannot be jammed
or malfunctioned even when the bottom of
the pool is a wash with viscous liquids
like that coal tar the vacuum will
continue to operate as normal scrubbing
away at the floor of scp-242 the one
part of the self-cleaning pool that
doesn't work as you would expect is the
water filtration system there is never
any water being cycled into the pool nor
out of it as a matter of fact the pipes
connecting to the filtration system have
all been removed then again who needs a
filtration system when your backyard
swimming pool can just spontaneously
reduce anything to clean water but that
raises another frightening thought
everything that the pool has ever taken
and converted is still in there animals
objects people just swimming around you
perhaps if they could still think they'd
scream and shout and tell you to get
away to run while you still can but the
second your skin touches the water
you're destined to be with them forever
and ever and ever it's enough to send a
liquid chill down your spine okay so if
it's not the actual physical pool that
causes these anomalous effects that must
mean it's something in the water right
perhaps some microscopic flesh devouring
microbe or some ancient curse that was
placed on the water before it was used
to fill up the pool surely if you took a
cup of water out of scp-242 it would
still break down structures on a
molecular level leaving only more
sterile water well the researchers
working at the SCP Foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of
scp-242's water one test involves
submerging two d-class test subjects
each wearing an atmospheric dive suit
into scp-242 the goal was to determine
if it was safe to consume the water from
scp-242 while both inside and outside of
the pool test subject a was lowered into
the water and instructed to drink from a
metal straw by their mouth the eyepieces
of their goggles were blacked out so
they couldn't see what they were
drinking from subject B filled a barrel
with the same water from scp-242 and
then was made to put on an atmospheric
dive suit but instructed to stay out of
the pool test subject a was told to
drink directly from the pool remarking
that the water was warm and had a bit of
a noticeable chemical aftertaste but was
otherwise normal then test subject B
drank some of the same water from the
barrel apparently it was cool and taste
instead of well nothing just like water
usually does after a moment more of
drink subject a began belching finding
that they had uncontrollable gas the
water had begun to feel warmer stinging
the subject's mouth while for subject B
the water from the barrel stayed cool
and refreshing the foundation doctors
overseeing the experiment instructed
test subject a to keep drinking which
they did until it felt even hotter to
The Taste one of the d-class's fillings
even fell out and eventually the
structural Integrity of subject A's dive
suit failed presumably disintegrated by
the water from scp-242 after a few
muffled screams and gurgling noises test
subject a wasn't heard from again and we
can all probably guess why as for
subject B they kept drinking from the
barrel suffering no adverse effects even
after 17 long hours there were no
noticeable psychological or physical
changes even their urine showed no
traces of abnormality the water from
scp-242 left in the barrel evaporated as
normal leaving behind no residue or any
indicator as to why taking the water out
of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool perhaps the
moral of the story is to just be careful
where you choose to take a swim
otherwise it could be your last you're
on a road trip the kind that stretches
over days on end and you need to make
multiple stops along the way to refuel
the car and yourself the last time you
remember stopping to get more gas and a
bite to eat was back in Wyoming and now
you're in the heart of Montana
thankfully like an oasis in the desert
you see the town of Clearwater off in
the distance it's a vibrant welcoming
little place a perfect slice of classic
small town Americana you took a similar
trip last year and vaguely remember
stopping at Clearwater that time too and
you're glad to be back in particular you
remember the old Prairie Diner a full
folksy little place with the most
delicious Huckleberry pie you ever
tasted perhaps it's about time for you
to give it another try you fill up your
tank and stop at the diner the food
tastes just as good as you remember but
one thing is off the entire staff seems
to have changed it is the exact same
Diner you ate at a year ago no doubt
about that but it looks like everyone
from the wait staff to the cashier to
the cooks have all been replaced you try
your best not to think about it after
all businesses are allowed to replace
their staff but the longer you sit in
the diner the more uncomfortable the
feelings become you need to ask someone
just to push away the fears that you're
not going crazy when the waiter passes
by you compliment the food and mention
you ate here last year too you asked the
unfamiliar waiter if they had worked
here back then they confirmed that yes
they've always worked here and so has
everybody else the diner is a family
business you leave town not too long
after that feeling vaguely unsettled and
as a voice on the radio warns about the
incoming rain you tell yourself that you
never want to return to the town of
Clearwater Montana as you leave the
memory of the Town seems to fade from
your mind in real time but little do you
know the people of Clearwater will never
be able to leave ever it's because
something horrifying will happen in
Clearwater every single year and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as
scp-3300 this annual anomalous event is
Clearwater's own local curse always
occurring around mid-june while many of
the mechanics of this event still elude
the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
scp-3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any Outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
dreary drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a Maelstrom flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around clear
water but cutting off neatly just beyond
it what happens in Clearwater remains in
Clearwater and when the process has
concluded and The Sun Shines once more
everybody has been changed whenever the
foundation has tried to send Personnel
or equipment into Clearwater during
scp-3300 one of two things has happened
in the more favorable scenarios those
attempting to enter Clearwater have
simply appeared on the other side of the
city limits in the less positive
instances personnel and Equipment have
been lost forever within there is no
stopping or even understanding scp-3300
according to Foundation records
Clearwater has been around at least as
long as the foundation itself perhaps
even longer Clearwater has been able to
undergo its yearling nightmare without
intrusion due to a unique Cognito
hazardous effect which creates a kind of
mental block around memories of the town
for Outsiders you won't forget clear
water per se but you will find it
increasingly hard to focus on like
something you can only ever see out of
the corner of your eye there is no
saving the people of clear water the
horror will play out again and again and
again the foundation is no firsthand
knowledge of what happens in Clearwater
during those horrifying 18 days but one
account they have hints at a terrifying
possibility during an Excursion into
Clear Water the foundation managed to
collect a diary belonging to a woman
named Margaret Lane to the best of our
knowledge Margaret Lane no longer exists
but if the contents of her diary aren't
to be believed then what goes on in
Clearwater during scp-3300 is far worse
than we ever imagined Margaret first
started her diary not long before
scp-3300's 1995 iteration began she was
in the middle of a tumultuous time in
her life freshly cleaned from alcohol
and drug addiction forced to live with
her antagonistic mother and having
peculiar and distressing dreams in the
first Dream Margaret recorded she was
someone else a woman living in a small
Hut perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedrin her skin covered in
painful looking red blotches her husband
was already dead that's when another man
enters a healthy man he tells her that
he's found their salvation and then the
dream ended Margaret woke up to a gray
dreary day there were clouds on the
horizon the rain was come it drizzled
for the next few days before getting
more intense as one would expect from an
scp-3300 cycle of course nothing seemed
out of place to Margaret life carried on
she continued to stay clean resisting
the offers of her old dealer though her
relationship with her mother remained
Frosty the rain started to get worse as
voices on the radio insisted that
conditions would continue to become more
severe over the next few days they tried
their best to maintain normality
Margaret invited some friends Jared Sam
Mike and Isabelle to come over and play
D D at her place that was when all hell
broke loose while the group role played
there was a furious banging at the door
like whoever was knocking was trying to
bash the door down when Margaret's mom
opened the door to investigate the
commotion she saw that an entire family
was standing there a father a mother and
two young children the father
immediately began furiously asking why
all these strangers were in his house
when Margaret's mother tried to tell him
that this wasn't his house he became
increasingly agitated and walked
straight into the home Margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernatural
strength Margaret's mom ran in with a
golf club and struck the mysterious man
in the chest there was a nasty Splat but
he didn't seem to react the golf club
was just embedded in his chest having
broken the skin and sunk an end but
there was no blood just dripping water
the father then pulled the golf club out
of his chest and began beating
Margaret's mother to death with it all
while repeating my house again and again
while his wife and children watched with
broad Sunny Smiles in the rain somehow
Margaret knew that her mother was beyond
saving and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical
confrontation all they could do was run
out to Jared's van with the rest of the
group and hightail it to the police
station but when they arrived at the
station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever Madness was
going on here but that was easier said
than done they drove for what seemed
like hours on end as the rain and the
howling wind persisted Jared had been
injured during the fight with the
strange family and his health
deteriorated further as the drive
stretched on they should have left the
town of Clearwater a long time ago but
it seemed like they were nowhere it
wasn't long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van and now there
were only four of them left they kept
driving afraid grieving hungry and tired
and Margaret took the opportunity to
sleep it was no time to rest but she was
so exhausted that she had no choice
Margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague-ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the Villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and through
them the bodies became one with the
water and then they became the water the
water was everything when Margaret awoke
it was to the horrifying sounds of
bubbling and boiling that's when she saw
that Jared's body was dissolving now not
dissolving evaporating it was bubbling
and convulsing like it was made of water
until the entire thing burst into a
Cascade of hot steam after that Margaret
and the others left the vehicle and
refused to get back inside nothing was
making sense it was like something out
of a nightmare as they walked the rain
hammered down upon them they couldn't
have been walking for more than a mile
when they crashed into something it was
a sign welcome to Clear Water it was
like that the town itself had drawn them
back Mike refused to return to the town
of his own free will and began walking
in the other direction moments later he
was walking back towards them in silence
though he'd never end 2. scp-3300 had
distorted his path and brought him back
it was clear that Mike was shaken to the
core by the experience but they had to
press on they would head to the grocery
store for food and then to a sporting
goods store where they could hopefully
grab some guns to fight the violent
altered people who'd somehow appeared
with the rain but things didn't go to
plan or what little plan there even was
Mike shot himself on the first night at
Dirk's Sporting Goods leaving only
Margaret Sam and Isabelle alive perhaps
one of the most terrifying details of
Mike's death was the fact he didn't even
bleed instead the gaping exit wound in
the back of his head was just full of
water water was all that seemed to be
left of them Sam seemingly driven to the
Edge by the sight of Mike's death
grabbed a hunting knife to perform an
experiment she'd cut it into her own
skin and was horrified to see only water
dripping out they'd all been changed and
they didn't know why that's when the
survivors noticed something else there
were people standing outside in the rain
hundreds of them not a single one they
could recognize all new people waiting
Sam said only one word outside before
walking out of the hunting goods store
and disappearing into the crowd and the
rain never to be seen Again Margaret
Muse that perhaps in the end she had the
right idea to be taken killed or raced
or changed would be inevitable in the
final entry in Margaret's diary dreams
blend with reality as her mind finally
gives out from the terror she realizes
in her final moments that there is no
way out there is no Escape there is only
water water is eternal the rain is
eternal all will be changed and given
the fact that no trace of Margaret was
ever found saved for her diary all her
fears turned out to be right she was
taken and replaced by scp-3300 just as
will inevitably happen to all the
current citizens of Clearwater the next
time scp-3300 rolls around it will be as
inevitable and as indifferent to those
it affects as tomorrow's sunrise you
cannot change the rain but believe us in
Clearwater Montana the rain can change
you the year is 1985. 16th of February a
pair of researchers aboard a model sm03
deep sea submersible are descending into
the depths of the Atlantic Ocean hours
ago they were somewhere just off the
coast of France surrounded by Blue Sky
the smell of the Sea and the warm
embrace of the Sun but now only cold
Darkness surrounds them the depth of the
ocean so vast and overwhelming even
light could not Escape its grasp the
two-man team are members of MTF gamma-6
also known as the Deep feeders a special
task force that specializes in the
investigation and tracking of deep sea
or Oceanic anomaly days their mission to
locate and investigate the wreckage of a
World War II German warship known as the
Bismarck thought by the general public
to have gone down in the naval battle
with the British in 1941 but the story
the public doesn't know is the real
reason the para Foundation members were
tasked with locating the ship's wreckage
site unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they
dissipated radio Transmissions recorded
by the gamma 6 Duo detailed the events
that took place upon finding the
Bismarck designated
scp-4217 the Bismarck lay at the bottom
of the ocean partially submerged in the
sea floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous Naval engagements gamma 6
member Charles Miller comments even
after the better part of five decades
this ship is still in pristine condition
there is no water damage anywhere that I
can see even stranger no ocean sediment
has accumulated on the hull of the ship
whatsoever prompted to investigate
closer agent Victor Miller begins
operation of the cruise model rv-1
Marine probe an unmanned robotic
exploratory drone that allows the
researchers to explore the interior of
the ship's wreckage what they found
unnerfed them or better said what they
didn't find just as the outside of the
vessel appeared free of any corrosion or
wear the interior of the ship was just
as Immaculate the hallways were clean
the walls adorned freshly painted signs
in still legible German even the Nazi
symbols painted onto Command Center
still held no sign of disintegration it
was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line but strangest of all was
the lack of skeletal remains at the time
it was sunk the original crew of the
Bismarck boasted a minimum of 2 000 men
where were the bodies continuing the
mission the researchers piloted their
unmanned drone down the Erie winding
corridors along several of the inner
corridors of the submerged wreckage of
scp-4217 the crew find large thick walls
of what appear to be made out of a
rubber-like substance soon they find
that the large vein-like growths extend
throughout the interior of the ship like
tendrils growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the Craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubber-like substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle-like grounds the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with Dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team Hears A Distant Rumble growing
steadily louder suddenly the ship begins
to move shuffling sand and debris strew
along the sea floor clouding the
visibility of the ship terrified the
pair hurried to try and disconnect the
cable attaching the probe to their
submersible and Evacuate the sight but
it's too late a booming thud shakes the
underwater craft as a large Shadow
covers the glass window of the
submersible alarm systems go off as
cracks start to appear in the glass
surface the pair attempt to Pilot The
Vessel up towards the surface but they
are halted by a strong force pulling
them downward just as the cracks start
to spread across the surface of the
glass A giant shadow looms over the
submersible
what is that screams and the sound of
shattering glass can be heard on the
recording as the submersible implodes
from the pressure of the watery depths
since that unfortunate incident
Foundation members have recorded
multiple occurrences of scp-4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
Atlantic particularly off the coast of
the United Kingdom and as far north as
the Greenland sea given its cutter
containment classification containment
of scp-4217 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation Naval forces
with the cooperation of the British
royal Navy in episodes of aggression or
in agitated or hostile State Naval
forces are instructed to forcibly subdue
scp-4217 through Naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained
scp-4217 enters a passive State and
re-submerges
scp-4217 is divided into two parts
scp-4217-a is the Bismarck itself a Nazi
era War outfitted with an array of eight
main guns 44 secondary armaments and
dozens of units of anti-aircraft
Weaponry
scp-4217-b refers to the anomalous
cephalopod organism embedded inside the
hull of the ship
scp-4217-b has two large rectangular
pupils inside of octopod eyes that
protrude from the base of the ship as
well as 12 100 to 200 meter long
tendral-like muscular appendages that
extend outward from an opening in the
stern of the vessel
scp-4217 is deemed to be classification
risk class dangerous with reports of it
emitting a mild psionic field within a
20 kilometer radius confusing anything
within range and increasing the
likelihood of Friendly Fire among enemy
combatants
scp-4217-a's Hull seems to have the
ability of inorganic regeneration as
damage incurred from enemy vessels seems
to immaculately repair over time
researchers have a observe what appears
to be runes or cryptic markings on the
side of
scp-4217-a's Hall It is believed these
symbols were part of the original ship's
design to bolster the vessel's defense
Integrity though not immediately visible
when the vessel is taking fire the
symbols appear to Glow in proportion to
the amount of damage being mitigated
among its offensive capabilities apart
from the standard armaments of a World
War II era warship
scp-4217-a also has specialized
Munitions of an unidentifiable gas
compound that is reported to have
mutagenic properties individuals that
have been exposed to the gas compound
undergo rapid spontaneous metamorphosis
at a molecular level growing an array of
evolutionary attributes which include
the accumulation of reptile-like scales
or a feathers in place of skin the
increase or decrease of the number of
Limbs digits or even ocular olfactory or
auditory organs and in one reported case
an event where multiple members of One
crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning organism the more
study into this particular incident is
needed
scp-4217 also has the ability of
subsurface Oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels underwater propulsion
appears to be generated by the ejection
of water from
scp-4217-b's body cavity and reaches a
top speed of approximately 30 knots
scp-4217 undergoes cycles of passive
behavior that is periodically
interrupted by moments of hostility
towards civilian craft particularly
resurfacing and going after
transatlantic cargo vessels it is
believed this is analogous to the
history and original Mission of the
Bismarck operation reinenbung during
World War II the German luftwaffe was
besieging London in a series of nightly
Air Raids that would be colloquially
known as The Blitz it was the Grand
intention of the Third Reich to cut off
supplies to the British to limit the
resistance to the Nazi war machine
however what pestered the Nazis most and
hindered this effort was the consistent
American Support provided by the U.S
government in the form of food and
supplies delivered to the British via
Atlantic trade routes by cargo ship the
German Bismarck and her sister ship the
tirpitz were created for the very goal
of stopping these transports of cargo to
the United Kingdom as well as sinking as
many Allied vessels as possible the year
is 1937. in a top-secret effort to make
preparations for an approaching War
Adolf Hitler turns to his most trusted
expert on the supernatural Chief SS
officer Heinrich Himmler among other
projects Himmler ordered the anarbe
obscuracore a German organization tasked
with a procurement and investigation of
Otherworldly or otherwise unexplainable
phenomenon to begin the creation of two
ships the Bismarck and the turbids the
former named after the Iron Chancellor
Otto von Bismarck who in 1890 unified
the German people these vessels were to
be created using recently uncovered
technological Oddities the obscuracore
had found in their studies of the occult
sources of information about the exact
creation of scp-4217 are highly expunged
from the record but bits and pieces did
survive among what little the foundation
was able to collect and in the records
of the USSR after their occupation of
Eastern Germany following the fall of
the Nazi regime during the second world
war the earliest mention of scp-4217's
conception dates back to early 1937 when
a top-secret shipment of unknown
materials labeled components of
thomatological constructs is intercepted
by a foundation agent working undercover
in a German shipment Center outside of
Hamburg the foundation ancient Marcus
Straub is instructed to maintain
surveillance on the shipment in 1939
upon near completion of the soon to be
christened Bismarck a second shipment
labeled with the Insignia of the obscura
core is intercepted by the foundation
agent only this shipment appears unlike
any other reports of the massive
shipping container holding Machinery
capable of Aquatic Life Support indicate
organic living cargo though the
foundation agent was unable to identify
the exact nature of the contents of the
shipment Straub reported hearing sounds
emanating from the cargo hole sounds
similar to that of a heartbeat just a
year later the Bismarck is seen making
its first Naval trial run when it
experiences a massive electrical
discharge just offshore shutting the
vessel down momentarily until power was
restored shortly after reports show
luminescent symbols briefly visible on
the hull of the ship thymotological
symbols for the laymen are symbols that
embody the study of Miracles because of
this it was apparent to the foundation
that some occult anomaly was responsible
for the strange characteristics of the
German vessel and in order for
termination was reached by the o5
council the hunt for
scp-4217 in the Autumn of 1940 under
orders of neutralization of scp-4217 all
active Foundation agents presiding in
Germany were ordered to converge on the
site of the Bismarck to stop the
completion of the vessel but when the
time came for the operation every single
one of the foundation agents vanished no
records of what happened were ever found
no clothing notes not even a trace of
their existence was left behind the
mission was deemed a failure and
subsequent attempts to neutralize
scp-4217 became far more difficult after
the Bismarck received a full crew of
semen the fully manned and well-equipped
scp-4217 became a menace to both
military and civilian Craft on the high
seas of the Atlantic at times appearing
without warning seemingly out of thin
air
scp-4217 psionic field obscured it from
the new technological advancements in
enemy radar systems the US government
had in development the ship became a
shadow on the Atlantic a subject of
ghost stories for anyone daring to
assist the British government with the
war effort furthermore scp-4217 did not
seem to be content with the surrender of
enemy vessels captured enemy ships were
gassed turning the men into manufactured
beasts and then sinking the enemy
vessels to the depths of the ocean even
submarines were no match on one report
describing an attempt to elude The
Vessel by diving below the surface only
to be entangled by enormous squid-like
appendages that dragged the craft back
up to the surface before crushing it in
its grasp fearing the safety of the
public the o5 council decided they could
not stand by and let more innocent lives
be taken they voted to supersede the
foundation's policy on absolute secrecy
to notify the British government of the
danger
scp-4217 posed to Maritime civilians
with cooperation from the British royal
Navy Foundation represent joined the
crew of HMS hood and HMS Prince of Wales
to track reports of the Bismarck being
cited off the coast of Scandinavia in
what history books would come to know as
the Battle of Denmark Strait HMS hood
and HMS Prince of Wales engaged
scp-4217 and a secondary German warship
known as the prince yojin confused by
the ship's psionic field the British
naval ships experienced trouble
identifying the Bismarck and engage in
Friendly Fire before being able to
regain control of their armaments
concentrating all volley of fire on
scp-4217 the attack proves futile as
after the Embers and smoke of Munitions
fire wear off the sides of the
bismarck's hall appear to vibrate with
glowing energy mangled metal begins to
straighten back into perfect frame
breaches and armor begin to heal before
the Soldier's very eyes and all that is
left as evidence the ship had ever taken
fire is a cloud of steam emanating from
the hull of
scp-4217 the water surrounding the
vessel begin to boil as underwater
tentacles Lurch out and capture the HMS
Hood dragging her majesty ship forward
the men aboard frantically try to regain
control but seconds later are met with
another crisis a salvo of artillery
shells fired from
scp-4217's Guns hit the ship severing
lines and damaging railguns as a
mutagenic gas compound starts to spread
among the Royal seamen in mere minutes
majority of the crew are engulfed in
toxic fumes and experience vomiting and
convulsions their bodies undergoing
rapid involuntary mutagenesis including
the growth of Limbs the development of
fur feathers and scales and one reporter
was said that multiple victims even
fused together to create one single
horrifying entity those exposed to the
gaseous compound were designated
scp-4217-1 the captain of the HMS Hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of
scp-4217-1 overpower the ship and
neutralize command in the seconds that
follow any witness of the horror that
the men aboard the HMS Hood experienced
is forever entombed in the watery grave
of the British vessel as the ship is
sunk by a volley of Munitions fire from
the combined might of the German Fleet
some men attempting to jump overboard
and swim to safety are dragged down by
their legs by the mutated instances of
scp-4217 and pulled under lungs filling
with seawater as they scream until their
breath is no more in disbelief the crew
of HMS Prince of Wales decides to
retreat in the days that followed at the
bequest of foundation members the
British royal Navy launches a full-scale
Armada to hunt down and neutralize the
Bismarck though scp-4217 sustained
little damage in the previous encounter
the ship began leaking a black oil-like
substance thought by a CP researchers to
be an organic waste product of
scp-4217-b the Allied Naval forces are
able to follow the trail to the coast of
France where under the lead of HMS King
George V British warships surround the
German vessel and opened fire this time
they were ready with approval from the
o5 council Foundation members provide
the British forces with enhanced
Munitions and Armament capable of
overwhelming
scp-4217's thematological defenses on
the eve of battle it appears to the
Allied Forces that the psionic field
generated by scp-42 17 is too great as
the naval company find it difficult to
land targeted assaults on the German
vessel after losing several smaller
vessels to the Colossal appendages of
scp-4217 foundation members on board
authorized the use of a redacted SCP it
is brought in to deactivate scp-4217
psionic field the tide of The Battle
Turns and after a fierce battle
scp-4217 becomes immobile and unable to
return fire Relentless the British
continued their bombardment until the
artillery Munitions on the ship explode
into a giant Fireball flooding the
ship's compartments with the noxious
fumes of the mutagenic compound its crew
members either jump overboard or are
engulfed in the cloud of gas the British
vessels capture any survivors and
watches as scp-4217 slowly sinks below
the waves down to the depths of the
ocean where it would lay dormant for the
next 48 years
scp-4217's 121 surviving crew members
were captured and interrogated most of
the low-ranking German soldiers were
released to British custody 109 of them
having their memory wiped by Foundation
staff 12 remaining members of the crew
were sent to site-23 for further
detention and advanced interrogation and
74 of the instances of
scp-4217-1 the mutated subjects were
recovered and sent to site-23 for
further observation it was thought that
on that day
scp-4217 was deemed neutralized and no
longer a matter of priority the Bismarck
sunk into memory and myth it was only
until the recent Resurgence of
scp-4217 that the foundation saw the
need to collect as much information on
the organism inhabiting
scp-4217-a is possible decades-old
manuscripts and ledgers were pulled from
hundreds of viable sources from the
intelligence then gathered Foundation
members have come to the hypothesis that
the entity powering the vessel known as
the Bismarck as what is believed to be
extra planetary origin World War II era
documents uncovered between Commander
Carl reuter of the German obscuracore
and a doctor Hans Meyer indicated
discovery of an organic life form of
Unknown Origin found in a crashed
aircraft near feldberg Park in the black
forest mountain range in Germany further
correspondence with obscured core
members Otto Schmidt and Dietrich
klosner indicate that researchers were
conducting trials on the creature's
ability to create psionic fields and to
control or confuse enemy subjects within
its range with a letter from Dietrich
klosner suggesting the creature could be
used as a power source for an
unspecified engine further evidence of
scp-4217-b's extra planetary origin can
be found in a 1993 incident between
Foundation naval ship scps nimid and
scp-4217 this is the only incident on
record where contact was established
with the creature class specified as
scp-4217-b on July 22nd
scp-4217 had reappeared off the coast of
Britain anticipating hostility scps
nemed scps cesare and as CPS parthelon
were instructed to close in on
scp-4217's location with orders to
subdue The Vessel if necessary however
on this occasion
scp-4217 did not appear to be after any
vessel it was simply drifting along at
Sea no propulsion engines active
noticing the change in
scp-4217's Behavior Captain Kurt Wegner
decided to withhold military engagement
and investigate
scp-4217's Behavior sailing within 200
meters of the Bismarck the scps nemed
attempted radio contact with the German
vessel after repeated attempts at
communication the crew were met with
only silence and static chatter giving
up Captain Wagner puts down the radio
receiver once suddenly the sound of
music is heard playing over the speakers
of a ship the tune is the national
anthem of Nazi Germany the captain hails
The Vessel again repeating his attempts
at communication do you do you
understand me at first only static can
be heard then came a reply
[Music]
the ominous voice could be heard from
the speakers the captain hesitated for a
moment members of The Crew looking at
each other with apprehension the captain
replied confirming themselves as a ship
and then asking if
scp-4217 knew what it was and where it
came from what followed was the crew of
the scps nemed receiving a video feed
from
scp-4217 featuring a high volume of
images in Rapid succession among them
were images of German cities Adolf
Hitler's telecast of the 1936 Olympics
an unknown structure in outer space and
an increasing repetition images of the
planet Jupiter particularly the giant
storm on Jupiter known to the public as
the Great Red Spot or scp-2399 as
Foundation members know it the
transcript of the radio communication
between Captain Wagner and scp-2417
stops when the video feed begins to
focus heavily on images of Jupiter
scp-4217's responses become more erratic
and agitated as it repeats the words
storm cloud and red the markings on its
Hall beginning to light up and the
underwater Shadows of its tentacles
beginning to create whirlpools of
displacement under the bow of the ship a
shrill shrieking begins to flood out of
the speakers followed by a high-piercing
high-pitched beeping sound that
overloads the communication equipment
causing Sparks to fly as crew members
cover their ears and hide under control
panels the scps Nemet barely escapes as
scp-4217 becomes hostile using its
massive tendril-like appendages to
assail the naval combatants firing its
Armament in all directions after a
fierce battle the foundation Naval
forces were able to neutralize and
subdue
scp-4217 no further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer Robert Ballard in 1989
any recent sightings of the Nazi era
Bismarck are flagged as
misidentification by SCP staff for now
Foundation members continue to monitor
the behavior of
scp-4217 and protect the public from its
existence imagine this your researcher
with an interest in and an aptitude for
marine biology over the years your work
has taken you far and wild to the
furthest corners of the Earth's oceans
you've observed countless species of sea
life for fish and Crustaceans to whales
and sharks predators and prey alike
during one of your travels you find
yourself off the coast of South Africa
monitoring the local population of sea
creatures looking out across the water
you see a large dark shape moving below
the surface there is a shadow streaking
its way towards Your Vessel Dark As
night speeding Like a Torpedo you rush
across the deck leaning over the port
side as the shape swims Beneath Your
Boat you're certain you know what it was
after all your years studying the world
beneath the waves you know will shark
when you see one the largest known
species of fish still in existence the
whale shark is a filter feeder
consisting on a diet of Plankton and
other tiny aquatic organisms a whale
shark pose is absolutely no threat to
humans or rather any whale shark other
than this one would impose a threat but
how could you know that
scanning the water you strain your eyes
trying to spot what you assumed was an
ordinary whale shark swimming below but
there is nothing no sign of it anywhere
sighing you think you've might have
missed your chance to see one in the
wild perhaps it changed Direction
instead of swimming under the boat you
tell yourself the ship turns and starts
making its way back towards the small
Harbor leaving you blissfully unaware
that there's an extra passenger on board
as you disembark you notice something on
the side of the boat emblazoned on the
hall is a motif of a familiar shape a
whale shark depicted entirely in painted
dots stare at it for a moment intrigued
by the pattern it reminds you of a piece
you once saw in Aboriginal Australian
style of dot art you're a little taken
aback by The Coincidence having briefly
spotted a whale shark while out at Sea
earlier blissfully unaware that this
painting marks your first encounter with
scp-1449 known more colloquially as the
Dreamtime whale shark in fact you're so
amused by seeing the whale shark earlier
only to find one painted here on the
boat that it distracts you you don't
realize that the whale shark painting
hadn't been on the side of the boat when
you'd shipped out instead you pay the
crew and thank the captain for letting
you hire The Vessel for your research
and then head off by the time you make
it back to the nearby town and settle
down in after a long day on the water
the dotted painting of the whale shark
has already slipped from your mind
but as you begin drifting off and
everything goes dark you're about to
find out that your encounter with the
Dreamtime whale shark is only just
beginning you've never been a heavy
sleeper and rarely remember your dreams
any that you might have seem to pass out
of your head the moment you wake up or
are too faint for you to acknowledge
while you're sleeping but tonight is
different tonight you're dreaming
vividly in this dream water surrounds
you like it has your whole career but
this time you're underneath the surface
adrift in an empty ocean nothing around
you but endless blank sea if you feel
something in your hand something smooth
and moving gently like organic matter
something alive you find yourself
gripping the tail of a whale shark and
somehow as is often the way with dreams
you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that day
the one that swam up to your boat and
ended up sticking on the side of it as a
DOT art painting
scp-1449 has this latent ability while
it normally appears as a flat
two-dimensional piece of Aboriginal
Australian dot art the Dreamtime whale
shark can shift whenever it is under
water it still appears as a collection
of painted dots in this mistakeable
shape of a whale shark but in an aquatic
environment it becomes three-dimensional
and that's what you'd seen swimming
towards the boat not just a whale shark
but
scp-1449 within your dream you release
the Dreamtime whale shark's tail and
begin to float upwards
breaking the surface of the water you
breathe lung fulls of fresh air the
first thing you see is land and it's
close by close enough for you to swim to
shore paddling through the water you
reach an island one in a chain of small
landmasses tiny continents in a shallow
unfamiliar ocean you look back to the
water but can find no sign of
scp-1449 the Dreamtime whale shark has
brought you here and left you on this
island but you can only speculate as to
why there must be a reason you insist to
yourself the Dreamscape around you it
would seem as either the creation of
scp-1449 or at the very least a side
effect of falling asleep close by to
where you saw the Dreamtime whale shark
in its painted form whatever this place
is there must be some way to uncover an
answer it stands to reason you think
that if you can understand what's going
on then perhaps therein lies the key to
Escaping The Stream and waking up back
in reality
the small island you find yourself on
and the others nearby are inhabited by
strange life forms as you walk across
the shore sand clinging to your wet feet
you approach what you thought at a
distance to be a group of other people
instead you see a group of peculiar
beings they are not quite human but they
are definitely close the closer you walk
you notice these strange humanoid shapes
huddle tighter together their backs to
you when you try to call out to them
asking where you are or how you might
return to reality they bustle away the
wind carries the sound of their chatter
towards you and you're certain you hear
them call you another one just another
traveler from afar what you don't
realize lost in this dream environment
is that there are others like it pocket
worlds like this one similar but
different currently being experienced by
any others asleep near
scp-1449 as you Ponder what to do on the
beach the captain of the boat you hired
is on a different version of the same
island watching a herd of multiple 2 000
kilo platypi being shepherded by six
tattooed three meter tall humanoid
figures meanwhile his first maid is in
another version of this dream world
learning how to hunt under the tutelage
of a man called gray the rabbit Hunter
each version of
scp-1449's Dreamscape have separate
continuities to each other they are
differing copies of the same chain of
islands with the same inhabitants but
each visited by a different traveler
from afar in their sleep much like a
lucid dream visitors to the Dreamtime
whale sharks worlds can interact with
them shaping and altering events in the
continuity they find themselves in
deciding to leave the beach you will
like to make your way towards Higher
Ground to try to get a wider scope of
your surroundings fortunately there is a
towering mountainous shape nearby
standing like dark serrated teeth
against the clear Horizon you begin your
dangerous track ascending your way up
these dead Jagged Hills
you're still unclear on how you got here
or how to escape but you will yourself
to keep climbing knowing there must be
some way to wake up from this bizarre
dream finally reaching level ground you
take a moment to catch your breath
collecting your thoughts before
advancing any further you turn gazing
out over the landscape spreading out
below and all around you the island is
small enough you can see the shore where
you arrive and the ocean flanking this
land mass on all sides in this short
moment you appreciate the beauty of this
bizarre Dream World for the first time
the trees Sway in the gentle breeze
moving like the calm rolling of waves in
the water Beyond both glistening with
the warm light of the sun while it is
still true that you have no idea how or
why
scp-1449 brought you here or how to
leave you think to yourself that at
least this dream environment isn't a
hostile one not that you'd want to be
stranded there forever but there are
certainly far more unforgiving places
one can dream about a grim thought
suddenly Dawns on you how long have you
been here does time pass differently in
this world to the one you're still
asleep in as sound shakes your thoughts
back to your current here and now it was
a voice you're sure of it a voice
calling out but not to you traversing
the dead Jagged Hills you see a figure a
person from The Real World like you not
one of the local humanoids they don't
see you they're calling out to someone
in a ram shackle Hut cobbled together
from pieces of wood and other scraps on
the arm of the figure's dark
military-like uniform is a symbol and
you can just make out three distinct
letters s c p a wooden plank that
functioned as the door creaked open
revealing a second figure the man looks
disheveled his worn clothing patch with
scraps of leather and shark skin making
him looked as cobbled together as his
makeshift hunt like he was an extension
of the small structure he watches the
man talks to the agent overhearing his
words don't say anything if you say
anything I lose my mind you could say
anything and something horrible happens
the strange man warns talking too
quickly for the foundation agent to
reply you're a dreamer like me my name
is Nikolai I am the ships here of the
Dunham and the Brotherhood of
selectosticks combin the man Nikolai he
called himself seemed distressed
tripping over his words disagreeing with
himself until he starts trailing off
into swearing obscenities I'm not
Nikolai he shouts I am Angel
changing John before stumbling and
cursing again I'm sorry I can't can't
keep the memory straight being this
Lucid for these long hurts the dreaming
fills in all the gaps things have always
been even as they are brought into being
I've been on this Cliff since the
beginning of time just like how this
place has always been here the dream was
thrown away by the deaths of gods Before
Time began but I watched it happen five
years ago are you following
I can barely tell the dream and reality
apart anymore my world has always been
the way it is and we made it like that
we heard the dreaming the shark that's
how we see it we heard it killed it in
our world and the dream time poured out
like it spilled blood and we made this
big scar here and and things are wrong
fish walk and ghosts hunt the stones and
women give birth to plastic children and
the leach feels stretch out forever in
the Seas of human blood in the center
eats cocaine and caviar out of panda
skull balls on the crushed backs of open
mares in acres of broken glass and it
has always been like this don't don't do
it don't do it again you're already
racing back down to the dead Jagged
Hills the sight of the deranged Nikolai
burned into your mind
a man reduced to a babbling lunatic Cast
Away and left alone in this strange
Dreamscape that
scp-1449 brought me to but Nikolai is
more than that more than just someone
driven mad by his isolation he is a grim
prophecy of what will become of you
unless you can find a way to leave the
Dreamtime whale shark's World already
back on the beach you drop down kneeling
in the wet sand as the tide washes over
your knees the how or why of scp-1449
bringing you into this dream is an
important all that matters to you is
avoiding ending up like Nikolai whatever
it takes you know one thing above all
else you need to wake up but whether you
actually ever will is another question
entirely you edge the pool side chlorine
stenched air filling your nose the sound
of splashing and lifeguards whistling
bouncing off the indoor pool facility
wall walls the water ripples family and
friends egging you to Cannonball Inn the
pool almost beckoning you to jump with
its suggestive waves if there remains an
underlying fear one that brings your
hands to your face and causes your teeth
to chatter even as the pool clear us
glass with chlorine hides no secrets a
monster some teeth gnashing Megalodon
ascending from the depths of Extinction
Leviathan curling its Barbed tail to
strike its prey at any moment or even
some vast unknowable Force ancient as
Earth hardly comprehensible to human
Minds waiting dreaming to breach the
surface no matter what form this
gargantuan invisible monster takes you
know one thing once you jump in you will
not return to shore you take a moment
recompose yourself and laugh off the
fear maybe a product of too much
research on the blue that deep ocean
sound continuing to confound scientists
as to its cause or maybe too much
binging infographics videos on sea
monsters Krakens and Loch Ness Monsters
mysterious globsters cast onto Shores
throughout America whatever the origin
the thought seems ridiculous to you now
and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimeter
Escape your mind as you hurl yourself
into the water
scp-1128 in the vast Archives of a
hidden site stuffed into a drawer
amongst uncountable Horrors like it the
SCP Foundation holds a description of a
vast unfathomable horror that'll make
you more suspicious the next time you
pass a pool lake or even a bathtub or
puddle of water
scp-1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster
lurking in Waters unknown and that's all
the foundation will let anyone not
assign to testing know about it while
the foundation has never shed away from
those Moby Dicks of the deep including
the several thousand kilometer long
arthropod
scp-169 and has even utilized such
predators in the past for their own
benefit like the lengthy Beast scp-3000
scp-1128 poses a unique challenge anyone
who knows of its description Beyond
surface level details will fall under
the anomalies effect the representation
you see now is merely an artist's
interpretation of the basic prompt the
foundation of course had to discover the
monster's effects in the first place the
chain of communication becomes foggy but
a tip from an unknown source alerted the
foundation to the monster's existence
and details regarding its manifestation
one man who had stumbled upon the
entity's full description started
developing acute philosophobia fear of
large bodies of water not Bodies In The
Water mind you the man refused to relax
on the beach or fly overseas claiming he
could see the monster's dark silhouette
lurking underwater ever scouting for him
this eventually extended to even closed
bodies of water like lakes ponds and
pools still insisting that the creatures
swam under the surface trailing him
wherever he went his friends dismissed
him as crazy and he too believed he had
fallen under some hysteria he decided to
take a nice warm bath to soothe his mind
and ease his troubles he turned on the
faucet and let the tub fill up he put on
his best bathing suit ready to calm his
anxiety once and for all this had been
plaguing his mind for far too long and
he was ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia basically he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
over the idea of it all he mustered up
the courage and with the intestine
patient to just simply relax he took his
first confident step into
you pause for a moment and breathed a
sigh of relief he picked up his other
foot and stepped fully into the bath
Splash he fell straight down right
through the tub waves and Bubbles
blocked his vision his arms flailed as
he sung deeper into an abyss of water
and fear this wasn't supposed to happen
he thought several moments later while
still in a full-on panic the buoyancy of
his body began to slow his sinking the
bubbles from his underwater screams Rose
above him they began to follow their
Direction scrambling back up to where
he'd come just as he made it back to the
surface of the tub water choking and
hyperventilating in Terror he swore he
could see a distant creature the very
same that stopped him through oceans and
pools staring at him shaking he hoisted
himself out of the water and ran out of
the house hysterical he ran through the
surrounding neighborhood desperately
searching for someone he could relay his
experience to Blinded By fear he
neglected despite lot of puddle in the
middle of the road he ran on he raised
his foot arched forward and landed
straight into the seemingly shallow
water splash again he found himself
completely submerged and drowning after
a minute he did emerge from the puddle
but not in one piece knowledgeable of
this incident the foundation set about
expunging any traces of the monster's
description from the world physical and
digital the description had low
distribution according to the results of
foundation web crawlers but this hardly
stopped the foundation's Endeavor with
Forum posts deleted individuals located
and amnestotized and catalogs trawled to
ensure the description did not
proliferate the foundation engaged in
what it does best questionably ethical
experiments first they had an anonymous
d-class uninformed of the creature's
effect read the description of the Beast
while the pamphlet they gave him
confused him someone he didn't feel
particularly frightened by The Entity
and he she confusedly put on the diving
suit the foundation testers provided him
as they connected him to a cable and
told him to enter a bathtub the d-class
did as they instructed him the d-class
expressed initial confusion at the tub's
depth remarking that it looks so tiny
from the outside as the d-class
continued to descend he analyzed his
surroundings realizing the nautical
reality that enveloped him he asked how
an ocean got stuffed into a bathtub but
the test organizer had no room for
miscellaneous talk he continued to
descend until he hit the Sandy Bottom
seaweed covering the ocean floor the
d-class looked around tropical fish swam
in schools Coral covered the seabed and
to his right dropped an immense Cliff a
sheer Edge the test organizer advised
the d-class to approach the cliff and he
begrudgingly complied as he struggled in
his diving suit he fell back and
screamed scp-1128
aquatic horror swam distantly gracefully
even and paid no attention to the
d-class so fixated upon it he realized
that the creature matched the one he
read on the pamphlet and almost
complained about this when he saw a blue
whale swimming alongside
scp-1128 compared to the monster the
whale looked like a guppy the whale
glided in front of scp-1128's Jaws the
monster remained tranquil stared at its
prey and bit the whale in two with one
charm its teeth glistened in the water
the test operator requested the d-class
to pull back and as the cable began to
draw him toward where he came d-class
stared at the creature swallowing the
chunks of whale whole the d-class's eyes
remained fixated on the creature
partially in Fright harshly and off he
wondered how ocean trawlers hadn't
discovered such a giant Beast yet but
the world effectively under 100
surveillance something the d-class knew
far too well as a convey yet the d-class
recognized and if not comprehended
partially understood the ocean's
vastness and mystery the dark depths
reveal no inkling as to their contents
and a creature like a giant squid or the
coelacanth can remain in hiding for
centuries if not Millennia it held him
in wondrous thought to consider the
vastness of the depths when scp-1128
stopped and stared at the d-class this
feeling of Wonder was quickly replaced
with fear as the creature approached the
d-class pleaded with the test operators
for health as the test operators
accelerated the rate of the cable
returning the d-class took short shallow
breaths filling his body with dangerous
nitrogen as he ascended further
impairing his judgment he had devolved
into gibberish and screaming when face
to face the monster consumed its prey
the cable went slack and the test
operator pulled up only a broken wire
snapped the water turning a cloudy red
the dust operator knew that the
unprotected d-class had no chance at
survival against the monster but he
could potentially arm and shield them he
had another similarly ignorant d-class
once again dressed in the scuba suit and
enter the town however the test operator
placed the d-class within a shark cage a
lot of the movie Jaws and lowered the
cage in with another cable and winch
system while Unsure how this would fare
with scp-1128 the test operator remained
hopeful that the d-class could survive
and recount his story unfortunately as
the cage lowered into the tub the test
operator received no response from the
d-class until the line spontaneously
tightened snapped and
hoping to find the d-classes remains the
test operator only found shredded pieces
of metal torn and twisted like taffy the
test operator decided that he could
utilize the foundation's Arsenal to his
advantage and use an anomalously
toughened shark cage in his testing
perhaps using an anomaly like the
Clockwork machine
scp-914 he gained approval from his
higher-ups to undergo this procedure and
after some testing behind shining strong
as titanium shark cage which he placed
another d-class within hoping for a
success with the monster however proved
unsatisfactory as the same thing
happened as the previous task only out
any sort of metallic remains while
bitter that the monster had won again he
wondered where the cage had landed
meanwhile Foundation forces labored
tirelessly to find scp-1128's location
hoping to avoid any civilian contact
with the creature luckily a GPS signal
established itself upon the most recent
d-classes test with the tracking device
on the d-class signifying the monster's
General location the foundation had
redacted the location of the monster
perhaps in a vain attempt to hide a very
near threat from potential readers the
foundation set up a team of only the
most talented boaters in its forces
mobile Containment Force Kappa 12 sea
Devils upon arriving at the location the
sea Devils discovered the previously
enhanced shark cage completely undamaged
however closer inspection revealed
traces of human DNA on the bars though
the foundation could not confirm whether
the DNA belonged to the previously sent
d-class the test operator while glad his
shark cage survived the monster's attack
still found himself dissatisfied with
the overall results of the test he knew
he needed to quell this creature's
impact before a large population viewed
it or knew of it but the horrible Beast
had evaded all attempts at peaceful
interaction perhaps with a Madness not
unlike Captain Ahab yearning for the
death of his white whale the test
operator armed a d-class with a
specialized weapon designed to deal with
aquatic threats promptly this weapon
potentially another of the foundation's
precious Arsenal could potentially harm
if not kill the creature while he knew
the foundation's mission statement
forbade unnecessary destruction the test
operator felt it may turn necessary if
matters turn any worse thus he sent his
armed d-class through the tub once more
ready to engage the beast in combat the
attempt as one may expect did not last
long the d-class upon spotting the
creature aimed his weapon at the monster
and attacked it but rather than draw
Drive the creature away it only turned
intently upon the d-class as if it
desired a fight the d-class barely
managed to scrape scp-1128 before the
creature devoured the d-class leaving
the test operator once again
empty-handed defeated and without any
more resources to deal with the Beast
the test operator ceased his attempts at
besting the creature and followed the
foundation's more cautious approach
expunging any publicly found
descriptions of scp-1128 as needed and
diverting any vessels away from the
anomaly's exclusion Zone as maintained
by the Sea Devils while the creature had
proven treacherous in unexpected
situations prior engulfing the man who
first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle researchers could
hardly expect what would transpire a
d-class Afflicted with the monster's
effect and observed for testing avoided
all bodies of water as required
eventually however the d-class needed to
interact with some kind of water
drinking water in a joint between a
little water exposure or certain death
the d-class felt inclined to choose the
former he filled his cup with water and
for fun placed his finger into the cup
dropping it into the water
scp-1128 unseen on the outside violently
pulled the d-class through the cup into
its watery domain the d-class had not a
chance to scream this alarmed
containment staff now cognizant that
even the tiniest specks of water could
transport an Afflicted person into
scp-1128's ocean territory this proved
particularly strenuous when a new report
of a potential scp-1128 manifestation
arose an old woman isolated with her
cats and knitting supplies found an
article online with a description of the
monster frightened and disgusted by what
she read she closed the article and
continued on with her monotonous life
such a life would take a turn for the
worse however when she too developed
that all-encompassing water-based fear
her apart overlooked an outdoor pool and
one day looking outside she swore she
could see that same dark silhouette as
the
lurking in the water among kids and
parents playing she swiftly closed the
window curtains and taped the seam shut
allowing no light to peek through
eventually this paranoia affected her
hygiene neglecting showers and baths for
fear of the creature's wrath she swore
she could see the silhouette in any
individual droplet of water her skin
began to flake as she avoided water as
much as humanly possible cracks
developing on her arms legs and face
inflaming into rashes and itches her
scratching further increased the
flanking she even eliminated water from
her diet sealing the faucets with duct
tape and consuming exclusively orange
juice she threw out her cat's water
bowls dehydrating them they pleaded with
her as she continued to devolve avoiding
any contact with the outside world Eva
as it attempted to contact her
eventually a concerned neighbor
contacted the local police concerning
the situation and the case caught the
foundation's radar recognizing the
symptoms of a potential scp-1128
infection a mobile task force disguised
themselves as civilians to enter the
apartment building and potentially
interfere with the woman's condition
they enter the complex climbing up the
stairs with barraging equipment for
forced entry as would prove necessary to
use to enter the woman's apartment she
had nailed the door shut with wood and
sealed the cracks along the sides with
plaster in an attempt to keep out any
water vapor she had similarly blocked
the window with wood planks a horrid
miasma of dead skin and citrus filled
the apartment the old woman soaking it
in ever avoiding the dreaded monster the
foundation task force attempted peaceful
entry knocking on the door and asking if
anyone lived in the apartment the woman
couldn't speak if she wanted to her
throat had dried to near silence save
suddenly the task force and the woman
heard a rumbling noise outside thunder
rain the woman panicked and yelled don't
come in here in a froggy voice the task
force eventually decided they needed to
use their equipment and entered via
barrage the door collapsed in an
immediate dense air clogged the task
Force's sight blinding and choking them
the woman shrieked and backed against
the window inadvertently the task force
insisted they were here to help the
woman but she simply heaved heavily
saying something unintelligible in that
dry cracking voice the rain began
pounding in the window
as the task force attempted to gain hold
of the woman she resisted their
movements moving around the room while
the task force intentionally avoided
violent confrontation the rain grew in
its intensity as the woman continued
running around her apartment tripping
over her starved cats eventually she
fell back onto the window at which the
boards blocking it fell onto the floor
exposing the pouring rain fully she
screamed as she saw the silhouette of
the monster staring at her in every
individual raindrop one drop landed on
her skin and she violently vanished
pulled into a minuscule Speck of water
the task force collapsed from exhaustion
perhaps dreading their inevitable
amnestic treatment following exposure
with an scp-1128 afflict tea yet they
couldn't help but wonder what the old
woman saw in a single Speck of water
that could cause that degree of fear and
paranoia the kind of fear only caused by
entire oceans condensed into a single
droplet besides the monster what else
did she see in those multitude of
droplets the fish that populated the sea
the whale carcasses left behind by
scp-1128 the Sea Devils viewed from
below Drifting On The Water unsuspecting
just as one may view a grain of sand and
see the Sahara she two saw that raindrop
and viewed an ocean entire along with
whatever malevolent creatures inhabited
one may have more Sympathy for the child
reluctant to jump into the pool water
knowing not necessarily that something
inhabits that body of water but that the
body belongs to a cycle much larger than
itself larger than any sea or Ocean and
the only thing that can Traverse that
cycle is a monster a creature like
scp-1128 the task force went back to
their local site to report what happened
during the incident like so many
incidents the foundation deals with the
sum total of those that risk their lives
for the greater good is a couple memory
erasing syringes and another update to
documentation a description of scp-1128
remains in a stuffy Locker lurking in
weight among other horrifying stories in
the SCP databases Sea Of Terror just
like that test operator that attempted
best the monster could the foundation's
attempts ever surmount the possibility
of another person being Afflicted could
they conquer the sea and a member of
that task Force's dreams they perceive a
dark blue ocean and the distant black
shadow that resides within and from this
ocean they can view the bathtubs sinks
pools puddles cups of water and Rain
droplets of the world seen from below
although they know not what scp-1128
looks like they too experience the fear
it summons among those that do the
paranoia the fear although it may not
manifest directly in people's lives it
can always be observed stalking waiting
lurking under a murky surface watching
with hidden eyes hello SCP Foundation
Personnel welcome to Cognito hazards and
you episode code rejected this video
series is intended to teach you about
the protocol surrounding the various
Cognito hazardous anomalies currently
within Foundation containment when you
know better you do better and both you
and the secrets of our great
organization can stay safe and as anyone
familiar with a good Cognito Hazard can
tell you knowing really can make a
difference today's episode is about the
unique and dangerous
scp-2316 before we begin repeat after me
and be sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water a
little louder please thank you in order
to be educated about the following SCP
you must pass a vocal examination with a
cognitive resistance value of no less
than 14.5 through this video
presentation you will need to repeat the
phrase to ensure your score does not
drop below the approved threshold in the
event that you fail the test stay calm
and remain where you are until medical
staff can retrieve you remember safety
is a top priority when observing Cognito
hazards the Safeway is the only way
you're a cog in a very important machine
and we wouldn't want to have to
terminate you now would we one more time
please I do not recognize the Bodies In
The Water very good remember that you do
not recognize them no matter what you
might think you see your thoughts can be
very unreliable when you're around
scp-2316 according to our files on the
matter
scp-2316 refers to an anomalous
phenomenon identified in a Small Town
Lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water water which
you do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
Consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the Cognito Hazard
come into play it would seem that anyone
who looks at the bodies in the water or
learns too much about
scp-2316 as a whole begins to believe
the corpse is floating in the lake are
people they recognize perhaps they
remember their faces from childhood or
High School whatever the case may be
they become convinced that the bodies in
the water are familiar and that they
must approach them no matter how
familiar they might seem however you do
not recognize the Bodies In The Water if
a person attempts to enter the lake
reaching out to whatever instances of
scp-2316 they think they recognize more
bodies will begin to appear the more
bodies appear the more familiar faces
seem to manifest and the deeper the
person will venture into the lake
eventually the person is lost within the
Sea of bodies likely drowning beneath
the surface or simply becoming one with
a hive mind until they too are one of
the corpses there none of the
individuals who wandered into the lake
in search of an old friend or classmate
have ever been recovered there have been
no attempts to search the lake for their
bodies as it is unknown what effect
scp-2316 would have on the team assigned
to such a task though we can guess that
the outcome would likely be extremely
negative for all involved those who do
Venture into the lake simply disappear
never to be seen again if you look too
long at the bodies in the lake perhaps
their faces would surface alongside the
rest but it's best not to think about
that after all we do not recognize the
Bodies In The Water Foundation Personnel
are not allowed to approach
scp-2316 under any circumstances the
lake is only permitted to be observed
via dummy probes outfitted with video
and audio recording equipment no one is
permitted to observe any footage or
audio files collected unless they pass
through a screening for resilience to
Cognito hazardous anomalies the lake
that holds
scp-2316 has been fenced off and is
patrolled by guards with no prior
knowledge of or exposure to
scp-2316 anyone who attempts to approach
the lake and break through the
boundaries of its quarantine will be
seized and taken to site-33 for
examination anyone who comes within 50
meters of the lake is considered lost
and presumed dead repeat after me slowly
and clearly into the microphone I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water good I
almost believe you let's continue only
one Foundation officer that entered the
lake containing
scp-2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost their name has been
stricken from any of official records
and you do not need to know it their
identity does not matter what matters is
the interview they gave following the
incident conducted by Dr Harrison in his
office Dr Harrison asked the anonymous
officer if they felt compelled to enter
the Water by an invisible force as if
pulled in they rejected this concept
entirely insisting that they entered the
water of their own free will they wanted
to see the bodies who appeared to them
as their friends they wanted to hear
what the bodies were saying upon
entering the water they saw the faces of
their friends other faces were
unfamiliar but became more familiar the
longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong it was
like the face of someone in a dream
where you can tell they are someone you
know and you can even identify who it is
supposed to be but something about them
does not quite look right your mind
could not perfect put their face
together from memory even though the
feeling of familiarity Remains the faces
in the water peering up through the
darkness below were like those dream
adult Memories the faces in the water
did not open their mouths but somehow
they spoke to the officer just the same
they spoke of who they were and asked
for help they asked to be seen to be
touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at Dr Harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the subject still as they fought
yelling at Dr Harrison repeating over
and over that they could hear the body
speaking to them every single one the
interview ended when the guards removed
the subject from the room taking them to
the amnestics department to have all
memory of the Bodies In The Water erased
from their mind then they were forgotten
once more I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water did you repeat it good we
do not recognize the Bodies In The Water
we can't the motivations of
scp-2316 if it has any at all are
largely unclear there are those on the
research staff that theorize the hive
mind or Collective consciousness of the
bodies is not malevolent in nature it is
they believe simply trying to make sure
that a tragedy that occurred in that
lake is remembered perhaps many lives
were lost to an anomalous force in that
Lake and the impact of that massive
tragedy left behind an impression on the
location this impression manifests in
the form of bodies spontaneously
appearing in an impossibly
well-preserved condition the Cognito
Hazard of
scp-2316 is not intended to kill anyone
one or take them but rather to force
strangers to remember the people who
lost their lives to the lake this sense
of familiarity whether it is false or
not ensures that the dead will not be
forgotten or left alone after all no one
deserves to be left alone though there
have been lives lost to the Cognito
Hazard according to the foundation it is
understandable why the bodies would want
to be recognized to have someone
somewhere know who they were to have
someone remember their names Jeremiah
Feynman Arthur Scott Denise Clark
where was I oh yes repeat after me once
again I do not recognize the bodies in
the water I do not recognize them I do
not
but that's a lie isn't it I do recognize
them how could I not I know them they're
my friends do you recognize them look at
their faces don't fight the memories
look into their eyes the class of 1975.
they were supposed to graduate that fall
they were just kids group of innocent
kids lost to the dark and deep what
happened to them I can't quite remember
but I know that it mattered enough for
the foundation to keep the secret and I
know that somehow I survived but I
shouldn't have I should be there with
them I should be there there isn't much
time I can hear the guards coming to
retrieve me their footsteps thundering
down the hall I failed the test and the
alarm has gone off they think I'm lost
but I'm not I've never been less lost in
my entire life I finally woken up to the
truth I remember I have to go I have to
return to the lake fall of 1975 they
went for a swim my friends they're
calling to me I can hear them so clearly
even from so far away their cries for
help ringing in my ears their voices
curling around me pulling me to the edge
of the water the guards will come for
you too they'll know you've seen this
they'll call you compromise they'll say
I succumb to the effects of the Cognito
Hazard they'll say you did too you'll
fail their little tests and they'll say
that makes you weak and broken but you
cannot listen they're lying it's not a
hazard it's a scream for help they're
screaming and the foundation keeps
covering it up they won't let us find
them and they won't tell us why I have
to go back so we can be together again
there are signs posted all around the
lake danger drowning Hazard those are a
trick it's to keep me out
to keep the truth from me the barbed
wire fences around it it's just another
trick I'll climb over it wrong after
wrong I don't care if the barbs tear my
clothes or pierce my skin it's worth it
for the truth for the memory and once
I've climbed to the top I'll be able to
see there through the fog I can see
their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me my friends my family every face
unlocking a memory long buried I know
them all and I must go further I can't
turn back now I have to wade into the
water let its chills soak into my
clothes down to my bones one step and
another deeper and deeper the water
lapping at my ankles my knees my thighs
the deeper I go the more sure I will be
that this is where I belong the water
will engulf my chest my neck until my
feet no longer touch the ground I will
be lost in it water flooding into my
mouth pouring into every opening I will
let my body sink down down down to the
bottom where they've been all this time
nestled in the dirt and the dust they've
been so patient but it's finally tied
they're ready to be remembered to be
seen to be found they're waiting for me
and they're waiting for you too can you
hear them I'm going now you have to find
me you have to follow me don't let the
guard stop you don't let them wipe it
all away from your mind fight Break Free
and find the lake hop the fence make
your way into the water you can't leave
me there to fade away floating in the
cold with the rest can you hear us we're
waiting it was a beautiful day in
Sardinia the second largest Italian
island in the Mediterranean the sea was
clear the air was hot and the beaches
were golden but the cagliari diving Club
couldn't see any of that they were
roughly 250 meters underneath the
Mediterranean Sea given the rich an
extensive history of the area they were
sure to find some interesting historical
artifacts on the ocean floor and they
were indeed about to find something
incredible but this history wasn't quite
as dead as some old Roman Pottery Paolo
Bonicelli the most experienced diver was
the deepest of all they decided to be a
little more ambitious this time than in
previous Dives 20 miles off the
Sardinian Coast for Paolo it was
Uncharted Territory so you could only
imagine how amazed and delighted he was
when he saw the shape of what seemed
like a small town beneath the water Old
Stone buildings in a classic Roman or
Grecian Style with roofs made of
thatched seaweed he gestured to his
fellow divers to follow him they were
amazed at how well preserved the
building seemed to be as though they
were still being lived in and actively
maintained to this day despite being
around 300 meters under water if they
were able to take some pictures and
collect some artifacts they'd be the
talk of the local historic community and
probably be able to finagle a payout
from the whole experience too that's
when Paulo spotted something truly
amazing a larger more impressive
structure like a miniature Palace
surrounded by grandio statues of
humanoid figures in a circle around the
little Palace each of the statues was an
imposing five meters tall with a faint
Golden Light emanating from each of them
while the statues were humanoid they
definitely weren't human their features
were strange and fish-like scales gills
tentacles Paulo was an awe at the sight
of them he took pictures and got closer
there was also a huge chasm in front of
the building perhaps some kind of
underwater thermal vent Palo was curious
he wanted to investigate further he swam
deeper and deeper what was at the bottom
of that Chasm the lucky for Paulo he
would never see what was at the bottom
of that Chasm before he could reach it
something intercepted him from the side
something large and fast he felt a white
hot flash of pain as claws raked across
his chest tearing open the rubber of his
wetsuit Paolo turned eyes widening in
horror to see a creature staring at him
like the statues it was humanoid but not
human an anthropomorphic sea monster
with greenish skin its arms and legs
coated in thin scales its neck serrated
into fleshy gills he could see scraps of
his suits rubber hanging from its claws
it bore a mouthful of fangs and gave a
silent but threatening snarl Apollo
could see something in the distance
behind this creature more figures like
this one emerging from The Merc getting
faster getting closer Paula was a smart
man but it didn't take a genius to
realize that if he stuck around
something terrible was about to happen
to him and the rest of the cagliari
diving Club he turned and fled paddling
with all his might away from the coming
Legion of aquatic beasts the rest of the
club saw the experienced diver panicking
and followed his lead thanks to their
quick thinking and expertise they all
managed to escape with their lives and
only a few minor injuries but they had
no idea of the true extent of the
mystery they were leaving behind beneath
the sea the Multiverse is a big place
there are alter universes where the
Devourer of Worlds escapes and destroys
everything we love and hold dear there
are alternate universes where the SCP
Foundation has gone haywire and
attempted to wipe out Humanity through
controlled releases of all their
anomalies there are even universes where
a kill Squad sent by the chaos
Insurgency hunts down and assassinates
every member of the o5 council before
replacing them and leading the
foundation into a bold New Era and there
are some universes where the SCP
Foundation is Italian we've covered
scp-057 on this channel before in our
video on the most frightening rooms in
the SCP universe but you've never seen
this
scp-057 because this is the Italian
version
scp-057-i-t this localized anomaly off
the coast of Sardinia is under the
purview of the Italian division of the
SCP Foundation which works autonomously
with its own systems and terminology
this SCP is in a frightening room that
crushes its trapped victims together
this anomaly is an entire city 300
meters beneath the water of the
Mediterranean Sea everyone has heard of
the mythical lost city of Atlantis a
supposed underwater Utopia outlined by
such great historical Minds as the
ancient Greek philosopher Plato it's
something that people fantasize about a
beautiful idyllic Society Under the Sea
divorced from all the petty squabbles we
deal with up on land but is everything
really better down where it's wetter
let's take a look and see when Paulo and
the rest of the cagliari diving Club
Return to the surface they were happy to
tell anyone that would listen that they
encountered aggressive merman and an
entire underwater city off the coast of
Sardinia they even posted their photos
onto their official Facebook page along
with photos of Paulo's gnarly chest
scars that's when the Italian branch of
the SCP Foundation finally discovered
them and decided decided to intervene
the foundation dispatched an sir Squad
known as oreria notatia sirs are the
intelligence and research section of the
Italian SCP Foundation a kind of mobile
task force that investigates possible
informational leads Paolo and his team
were given amnestic treatment and any
evidence that they'd collected was
scrubbed from existence meanwhile
Lieutenant Marco levini leader of the
mobile task force ssm-2 Squad AKA Leggio
alantides was being dispatched to the
source of the problem
scp-057-i-t itself what started off as a
relatively straightforward exploratory
Mission soon took an extremely strange
turn the Vini and his men reported
activity down in the underwater city
observing from the safety of their
armored Foundation submarine while the
Aquatic humanoids living in 057-i-t were
undeniably the same species their
culture seemed to be split up into two
unique groups one group had thinner
scales on their arms and legs this group
was more numerous having at least 60
active specimens and was characterized
by their extreme aggression towards any
Outsiders as for the smaller group they
had thicker scales as well as a number
of eerily consistent injuries to their
hands feet and gills they were also
distinct from the thin scales in terms
of behavior as they were a far
friendlier more Curious bunch at times
members of this subset would approach
the submarine and regard it with
detached Fascination sometimes they
would even point at the submarine and
laugh though their reasons for doing
this are unknown eventually Lieutenant
levini was so confident in their safety
around the myrrh people that he and a
few other team members decided to
disembark from the submarine on a diving
Excursion and properly explore the
Aquatic City below this would prove to
be a dangerous tactical error on
levini's part during what seemed like a
routine exploratory mission levini was
ambushed by Squadron of thin scales
grabbed from behind and kidnapped he was
taken as a hostage and Spirited Away
into one of the city's various buildings
where a thick scale known as Leticia
acted as his Warden but levini soon
found that being under leticia's care
was a profoundly lucky turn of events on
his part both because it allowed him to
learn more about the situation and
because she was one of the small group
left in the city who hadn't become
dangerous Fanatics that's right the mer
people were in the middle of a heated
Civil War both from the observations of
levini during his captivity and later
interviews conducted by project head Dr
Giuseppe pastilla with some liberated
members of the thick scales they learned
that a terrible religious conflict had
broken out in
scp-057-i-t the accounts coming from the
rescued citizens Illustrated a similar
backstory to what the Italian Foundation
had theorized regarding the myrrh people
they were the descendants of people that
lived on the island of Nisa gross up to
the 14th century BCE before it was
devastated by a volcanic eruption
forcing them into the ocean where they
evolved the ability to live in aquatic
environments through anomalous means
since this change this new species had
been operating in Mediterranean Waters
migrating regularly in order to avoid
detection passing their way of life from
generation to generation as the world
changed and shifted above them in many
ways they were quite similar to humans
such as their reproductive habits they
mate and reproduce after a gestation
period more like animals than fish
though their gestation period is
slightly shorter than human beings at
six months they largely speak Latin
though the oldest myrrh person among
them also speaks ancient Greek mer
children born in Foundation containment
have shown strong language acquisition
skills as they have proven more than
able to learn modern Italian and even
more fascinating from a standpoint of
sociological study the mer people have
formed their own unique culture under
the sea and this is where the problems
started abstaining from the belief of
the Greek and Roman pantheons their
ancestors looked up to the mer people
instead worshiped their own group of
water-bound deities whose images were
reflected in the great statues in the
center of the town the large building
near the statues and the chasm was the
home of the mayor the town's de facto
leader however what had been a workable
system for centuries began falling to
ruin when a strange religious fanaticism
began to spread a cult-like group soon
formed and began holding ceremonies
where they worshiped a powerful entity
in the chasm known as the great eye this
new cult was known as The Cult of the
great eye of the Mediterranean or sea
gem for short what began as a fringe
belief soon became a frenzy and took
over the better part of the town with
the acolytes of the great eye proving
themselves more than willing to spread
read the gospel of their new deity with
violence some of the more arguing
non-believers were killed for their
heresy While others were simply
ritualistically mutilated in order to
prevent them from rebelling Leticia had
her own evidence of these targeted
mutilations the thin scales had cut the
Aquatic webbing from between her fingers
and toes making it harder for her to
swim away and Escape other suspected
Heretics were given the same treatment
the reason the thick scales even had
thicker scales was that they stole
forbidden technology from the mayor to
increase the strength of their scales
hoping it would help them better
withstand the torments of the acolytes
those involved in the stealing of this
technology were captured and summarily
executed for their acts of defiance in a
sense Letizia was protecting levini by
advising him against trying to escape
knowing the acolytes of the great eye
would kill him if he did she knew that
the only opportunity for escape would
come during the ceremony held by the
acolytes to honor their their
frightening Master when the day
eventually came as levini was running
low on everything from food to oxygen
everyone in the town was forced out into
the Town Center to witness the ritual
the acolytes gathered around the chasm
and began to chant in a frightening
unknown language as they chanted a
blinding light began to emanate from the
chasm and as blurry shapes emerged
nightmarish tentacled gastropods soon
began to take form truly lovecraftian
undersea monsters shortly after the
ritual the Vinnie and the thick scales
were able to make a break for it pursued
by the acolytes of the great eye it was
a close one but thankfully due to the
intervention and assistance of a trained
mobile task force the fanatical forces
of the acolytes were repelled and the
fleeing myrrh people along with levini
were rescued a number of thick scales
are now willingly confined at site knit
tuno an Italian Foundation containment
site where they have undergone numerous
interviews with Foundation staff
incidentally among them is the oldest
myrrh person previously present in
scp-057-i-t the only one who spoke
ancient Greek fluently it was different
from the others extremely different in
fact he was a deity made into flesh one
of the deities replaced by the
worshipers of the great eye this
unfortunate former God had done
everything to keep his people's lives
safe and peaceful but in spite of his
wisdom and best efforts hell had once
again broken loose not everything is all
well and good and
scp-057-i-t even if a human's body
changes their nature does not and the
worst parts of human nature seemingly
followed these unfortunate myrrh people
into what should have been their
Paradise under the sea but all hope
isn't lost if you were to judge the
entire human race on one community in
turmoil you probably wouldn't leave with
a very favorable impression of us either
correspondence with a French branch of
the SCP Foundation reveals that mer
creatures aren't just localized to one
warring underwater city in Sardinia
mermaids have also been discovered and
confirmed by Foundation field agents off
the coast of France 80 percent of the
oceans Still Remains unmapped to this
day who knows what else is out there
just waiting to be found water the
Wellspring of Life we've dealt with a
number of anomalous water sources on
this channel like
scp-006 the much sought after Fountain
of Youth or the terrifying scp-3280
where murderous water threatens to
destroy the entire world but we've never
seen anomalous water that behaves quite
like this before in many of the legends
of King Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of
the Lake this lady emerges from the
depths of the water gifting Arthur with
the enchanted sword it's an incredible
if impossible image a woman appearing
from within the lake rising up from the
bottom and breaking through the surface
it's safe to say that none of us have
ever seen anything quite like it well at
least most of us haven't in a small
unnamed English Village there was a
young woman who set out on a
particularly lovely warm spring day to
take a swim in a nearby lake while
waiting in the water enjoying the
sunlight and the gentle breeze on her
skin she saw a strange Ripple ghost
across the surface she stopped her
swimming staring at the motion she
expected to spot a fish or some other
aquatic creature instead the water
itself began to rise up Gathering and
forming into a shape before her eyes it
was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm invite
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this Lady of
the Lake reaching out her own hand of
Flesh and bone to touch this Impossible
Creature just as her fingertips reached
the water woman's own the figure
dissolved back into the lake with a
splash the young woman ran home telling
anyone who would listen about the
incredible thing she had seen that day
of course no one believed her that is
until word of her sighting reached the
only people who might take her claim
seriously the SCP Foundation they sent
operatives to the lake where they
managed to capture the shape-shifting
entity dwelling there
scp-054 also known as the water nymph is
a being made up entirely of water with
an average volume of 90 liters when it
is out of a body of water the being
tends to adopt the appearance of a
humanoid woman though it is capable of
taking on a variety of other shapes
including other humanoids animals and
various inanimate objects The Entity is
also capable of shedding its form and
effectively disappearing into a given
body of water in order to avoid
shrinking or possibly disappearing
entirely from evaporation
scp-054 is required to return to a
larger body of water studies of samples
taken from the entity's body or its
version of a body revealed that it is
made up of ordinary water there is no
apparent reason for its ability to move
and no thermal electromagnetic
biological or Supernatural anomalies
were detected the research team could
not determine what might make this water
alive and sentient and the nature of its
unusual properties is uncertain to this
day when scp-054 was first brought into
containment at site-08 it displayed
surprisingly congenial and curious
Behavior often walking around outside of
the water and taking turns mimicking the
shapes of various staff and scientists
that spoke to it its demeanor began to
shift towards suspicion and aggression
however following a series of
experiments and an incident involving
the research staff the first experiment
conducted on scp-054 sought to determine
what would happen if the entity was
denied access to any fresh water water
was drained from the fountain holding it
leaving only enough water for it to form
a humanoid shape but no additional water
in the base and to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time
scp-054 became visibly frustrated as the
water was being drained out of its
enclosure for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its containment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water in its
Fountain it became distant and even cold
to anyone who attempted to speak to it
054 only became friendly again once the
water in its Fountain was restored to a
pre-experiment level next the research
team opted to test scp-054 reaction to
extreme temperatures particularly
extreme cold the temperature of the
containment facility was slowly dropped
until the room fell below the freezing
point of water as the temperature
dropped 054 became sluggish and
exhausted it lost its ability to shift
between forms remaining locked in its
preferred humanoid female shape its
movement slowed more and more as the
room grew colder until the entity was
completely frozen solid portions of the
ice were chipped off and studied
revealing the crystals were identical to
those of ordinary ice after the Sub-Zero
testing the research team decided to
take things to the other end of the
spectrum and test the effects of heat on
scp-054 the subject was placed in a tank
outfitted with heating equipment and its
temperature was slowly raised over the
course of several minutes when the water
reached a temperature of 95 degrees the
entity's behavior became frenetic and
aggressive it pounded on the glass walls
of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous column and Cooperative nature
of scp-054 was nowhere to be found this
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
Fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this
newfound resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly docile self over time next
Dr seskel the acting head of the
research team conducted a study
involving
scp-054's memory and ability to be
conditioned The Entity was presented
with a series of increasingly complex
mazes and puzzles when it failed to
comply with the experiment or solved a
puzzle incorrectly The Entity was
punished with an electrical shock or the
release of silica gel into its body both
of these options seem to cause it a
great deal of pain and distress and it
was eager to avoid further exposure to
them scp-055
displayed impressive learning and
problem solving capabilities revealing
it is likely much more intelligent than
it was first presumed to be Dr seskel
observing the experiments and with the
effectiveness of his somewhat unsavory
motivational techniques quipped to his
research assistant that they would have
it trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48-hour rest period before
experimentation was resumed yet again
this time Dr seskel planned to expose
scp-054's water source to various levels
of acids and bases in order to test its
homeostatic capabilities beginning with
a 0.5 M solution of hydrochloric acid
prior to conducting the experiment Dr
seskel noted I have no idea what will
happen but if this thing incorporates
homeostatic mechanisms like I suspect
Zen V should get some insight into how
maintains its form he also noted that
scp-054's behavior was becoming
increasingly erratic but made the
decision to continue with the experiment
as planned
scp-054 displayed a now familiar
reluctance when it was removed from its
containment chamber and taken to the lab
it thrashed around in the fountain
splashing researchers with water and
retreated from them as they approached
in spite of its efforts however it was
removed from its Fountain and placed in
the experimental tank the solution of
hydrochloric acid was then dripped into
the tank and then all hell broke loose
as soon as the acid touched the surface
of its water
scp-054 became incredibly distressed it
Formed into the shape of a human face
eyes wide mouth open in a Silent Scream
Of Rage and pain the water churned so
aggressively that the lid of the tank
was shaken loose allowing it to escape
the boundaries of its containment the
water formed into two large hands which
shot out of the tank and grabbed the two
nearest researchers pulling them into
the water and exposing their skin to the
acid now present there as the men
scrambled to drag themselves back out of
the tank and their colleagues were busy
helping them
scp-054 took on its usual humanoid form
and ran for the door it then collapsed
into a puddle slipped under the crack in
the bottom of the door and made its way
down the hall it was apprehended roughly
10 minutes after its Escape by a team of
guards who froze it using canisters of
liquid nitrogen and then carried its icy
body back to the containment facility
the two researchers who had been pulled
into the tank experienced chemical burns
on their skin as well as significant
mental distress they were given
immediate medical attention and placed
on a leave of absence and all
experimentation on scp-054 was suspended
until further notice at the
recommendation of Dr Siskel 054's object
class was changed to Euclid
scp-054 is currently contained in a
watertight isolation room fitted with
climate control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed Fountain has been
placed in the center of the the
containment room filled with fresh
spring water in order to accommodate the
entity's environmental needs all
maintenance workers assigned to the area
must wear NBC suits while inside and
must spend 10 minutes isolated in a
drying room After exiting before they
are permitted to return to the rest of
the facility if 054 breaches containment
the area must be evacuated and the
containment chamber will be filled with
liquid nitrogen in order to freeze its
water solid as the entity is highly
sensitive to the conditions of the water
that houses it chemical levels and
volume of the water in the fountain must
be monitored on a regular basis and kept
at optimal levels for the health of
scp-054 during the course of its
containment following the incident
around the acid-base incorporation
experiment 054 has developed a distrust
of men as the researchers handling that
experiment were primarily male in order
to prevent future incidents and keep
scp-054 calm no male staff are to be
assigned to the team monitoring its
containment unit because five years have
passed since the last incident involving
scp-054 its object class has been
changed from Euclid to safe on the
recommendation of the lead researcher
assigned to its case of course caution
should still be exercised while
interacting with the entity this is the
SCP Foundation after all and just
because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't
still drown experimentation on scp-054
has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate The
Entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself Dr Reynard had
lost everything his job the respect of
his peers and if everyone else was right
perhaps even his mind it was 11 pm when
he staggered to the edge of Okanagan
Lake in British Columbia eyes and
judgment clouded with booze this Lake
could have been what made his career as
a researcher for the SCP Foundation but
now that bright future was slipping
through his fingers like the dry silt
beneath his feet he looked hatefully
across the endless dark surface of the
water and loudly cursed stupid empty
place just hours ago he'd been stripped
of his ranks and released from his
position at the foundation for wasting
the organization's time and resources on
frivolous personal projects frivolous he
thought what a terrible joke just
because the higher-ups refused to
acknowledge what was going out here
didn't mean it wasn't there Moonlight
shimmered off the water surface wait was
that Moonlight or was there something
lurking underneath the water to truly
answer this question if any answer is
possible at all we need to go back to
the beginning and ask ourselves a
different question how does the SCP
Foundation actually find most of the
anomalies at catalogs and contains it is
a simple question with a multifaceted
answer depending on the anomaly in
question for the most part the
foundation has a network of field agents
embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe including
rival groups of Interest like the global
occult Coalition and the Serpent's hand
if they so much as sniffed the strange
and unusual they alert the nearest site
director and the necessary Personnel are
dispatched to the scene there's also the
foundation web crawlers which are a form
of specialized software constantly
patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the foundation wants to
know about and one of the rarer but
still incredibly important methods of
finding scps involve looking into myths
and local Legends sure it may seem like
a good way to waste time and resources
but the crossover between recorded scps
and folklore is surprisingly common take
scp-1000 the formerly hyper-intelligent
Apes that were nearly the dominant
species on Earth until humans and a
certain capricious Force God pulled the
dirty trick on them they're better known
to most civilians as the legendary
Bigfoot or Sasquatch perhaps the most
famous Cryptid of all time or scp-1337
The Hitchhiker an anomalous spectral
entity that manifests in the cars of
those who don't pick her up and performs
horrific acts of violence against them
she's eerily similar to Legends you can
find not only all over the us but the
entire world of ghostly hitchhikers
intruding into the cars of unwary
Travelers and scaring them half to death
or worse if you're unlucky another case
where myths and legends pointed the SCP
Foundation in exactly the right
direction and of course there's
scp-136 the terrifying naked doll this
was an almost featureless children's
doll found inside an abandoned house but
for a long time in its presence can make
you the victim of a warped Apparition
that'll drive you half mad with fear
it's got such a detrimental
psychological effect on people that the
foundation has been controversially
using it as a torture method during
enhanced interrogation sessions with
captured members of rival groups of
interest and how did they find it the
foundation keeps track of neighborhood
rumors about haunted houses with
supposedly Supernatural inhabitants
clearly when it looks like it might
actually get results no myth or local
Legend is too big or too small to
Warrant an investigation from the SCP
Foundation it was with this mindset that
a younger happier and less strong Dr B
Renard set off with his team to Okanagan
Lake in search of what locals had
referred to as the legendary Ogopogo
we've all heard of the Loch Ness monster
the lake monster from Scotland that's
been turning heads for the better part
of a century and may be related to two
other similar scps namely
scp-3934 and
scp-5533 but OKO Pogo is Canada's answer
to good old Nessie while the Loch Ness
monster resembles a pleosaur the acapogo
is much more Serpentine with a long
coiling body covered in green scales its
long tail is said to be able to create
Fierce storms along the surface of the
water with its vicious whips killing
scores of unfortunate adventurers who
dared stray too close the name Oco Pogo
is also a palindrome meaning it reads
the same forwards as it does backwards
and is believed to have originated in
the novelty song from the year 1924.
however it's likely that the actual
Beast this somewhat Goofy name was given
to is is a much older fiercer entity and
for the sake of his reputation as a
researcher as he took a plane to the
Okanagan Valley Dr Renard very much
hoped this was the case of course he'd
explored the Legends heavily so much so
that he was sure there had to be
something to this whole thing the schwep
mech and Selix peoples the like dwelling
monster was known as naitaka which has
been Loosely translated into the sacred
creature of the water the water God and
most menacing of all the water demon the
Beast was often described in oral
Traditions as being a malicious
Supernatural entity with great power and
ill intent towards those trespassing on
its territory Legend has it that anyone
who crosses Okanagan Lake the supposed
domain of the okapogo needs to make a
sacrifice to the monster in order to
ensure safe passage those who refused to
give the sacrifice the Beast demanded
would pay a heavy toll being devoured or
dragged down to a watery grave never to
be seen again and this monster isn't
just some old folk tale either
contemporary sightings have dated back
to 1873 with both settlers and First
Nations people alike spotting the
Sinister Ogopogo in the intervening
years Dr Renard had poured through the
files on hundreds of sightings there
were a number of incidents in the 1980s
so much so that the environmentalist
group Greenpeace moved to have the
creature classified as a protected
species naturally official sources
decided against the idea claiming that
none of the sightings were of substance
in 1992 a vast shape filmed under the
murky water in Okanagan Lake was
suggested to be the legendary beast
however the FBI stepped in to deny the
validity of this case stating that the
Beast was much more likely to be debris
falling off a local tree disappointing
lovers of the strange and unusual
everywhere in 2011 nearly 20 years later
there was more video footage of a
sighting showing large dark shapes
moving underneath the surface of the
Okanagan Lake however this claim was
once again dismissed by all outside
parties claiming the shape of the Beast
underneath the water was more likely to
be a pair of logs bummer 2018 was an
exciting year for the Ogopogo with three
different sightings of the creature
being reported at different times
throughout the year Witnesses described
the creature as being a giant snake
around 50 feet long which is consistent
with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the Beast as well as
being over twice as long as the
reticulated python the non-anomalous
longest snake in the world so naturally
authority figures once again shot down
the validity of any claims that the
creature was actually real and out there
Dr Reynard found this almost funny they
didn't even need to suppress knowledge
of this creature if it really was out
there mainstream sources seem to be
doing their job for them and keeping the
creature covered up he once determined
though that he would be the one to prove
to his superiors that this creature was
indeed real and lurking in Okanagan Lake
he organized a number of varied
investigative missions from actively
trawling the lake itself to conducting
interviews with first-hand witnesses as
well as those who claim to see no merit
in their evidence and testimony Dr
Reynard noticed a strange phenomenon the
people who'd seen it firsthand were as
certain that it was real as the doubters
were that it was fake even for typical
Skeptics the non-believers seemed
shockingly Resolute that there was
really nothing down there and the
alleged photos and videos were 100 bogus
early diagnostic tests into the lake
directly overseen by Dr Renard seemed to
point to a creature clearly being down
there he found the direct testimony both
compelling and consistent with what he
and his team were catching glimpses of
so why were people so adamant that
nothing was down there it was almost
like the Ogopogo really was as mythical
as the First Nations Legend said and it
was casting a spell on all the
non-believers that's when it hit Dr
Renard like a perfect bolt of lightning
they weren't just looking at a
particularly large sea snake with
unnatural longevity here they were
looking at a sea serpent with Cognito
hazardous Powers it was a beast with a
perfect defense mechanism only those who
sought up close would actually believe
that the creature was real anyone who
found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of
incredulity nobody except those who
sought directly would ever believe that
it existed and thus even the most
intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain an elegant
and dangerous anomalous Hunter Dr Menard
had found himself a worthy opponent and
one that would help him make his Mark at
the foundation he drew up the file and
gave it the designation
scp-1933 before sending it back to his
supervisors they wrote back saying that
they didn't feel as though there was
enough of a basis in evidence to deem
this entry worthy of inclusion if Dr
Renard wanted to have his so-called
Ogopogo dignified with entry into the
SCP Foundation archives he needed to
back it up properly this presented a
problem to Dr Renard how could he
provide documentation and evidence for a
creature that had the defining anomalous
power of making all of its own
documentation and evidence seem phony he
was caught between a rock and a hard
place with only one solution create the
most undeniably high quality evidence of
the creature that the world had ever
seen not long after that his superiors
at the SCP Foundation would receive a
video file from Dr Renard according to
the notes on his report he set up a
track using an elk carcass to lure the
creature out of the water and capture HD
video of its feeding when the senior
researchers gathered around to watch the
video they were astounded and
animatronic a cheap rubber suit around a
somewhat janky robot like something
you'd see at a theme park how much a Dr
Renard spent on this absurd farce did he
think it was funny despite Dr Renard's
protests he was reprimanded severely for
this waste of foundation resources the
object class on his 1933 file was
switched to explained meaning a rational
non-anomalous explanation for The
observed phenomenon had been found
discrediting it and the 1933 slot was
instead filled with a strange fat man
dressed as Santa Claus whose bodily
fluids are all Irish Cream the ultimate
humiliation Dr Renard was left with
nothing and we joined him once again
where we started with Dr Renard standing
on the ledge of Okanagan Lake staring
hatefully into the water as something
seemed to move underneath if Dr Renard
screamed that night there was nobody
there to hear it his remains were
dredged out of the lake the next day His
official cause of death was listed as
drowning after an unfortunate boating
accident though the vote in question was
never found reports that his corpse was
found half eaten have mostly been
dismissed as rumors after all there is
no such thing as the Ogo Pogo a giant
monstrous crab-like claw is around the
throat of an unimaginably huge eel-like
Beast the beast's terrible writhing
tentacles wrap around and latch onto the
immense crustacean and then the high
intensity beams of gamma radiation start
flying all the while Legions of skinless
centaurs swim in the waters around them
relishing the violence and in the middle
a lone boat the scps Smither manned by a
team of mobile task force operatives
that does all it can just to survive
there are those who consider outer space
to be the ultimate achievement in
Exploration the one place that explorers
have yet to chart and understand however
some of the murkiest Mysteries in the
universe are on our own Planet deep down
at the bottom of the ocean 95 of the
deep ocean remains completely unexplored
and the little glimpses we have gotten
paint a picture of something truly alien
giant squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of
scp-3700
scp-3700 refers to a circular area in
the North Sea with a diameter of 800
kilometers the waters there are
abnormally deep for the region with the
sea floor resting at five kilometers
beneath the ocean's surface there are
two entities present in the waters of
scp-3700 designated
scp-3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 interactions between these
two entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
scp-3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 always interact on the spring
and fall equinoxes of any given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year seemingly at random
but what exactly are as CP 3700-1 and
scp-3700-2 aside from terrifying
creatures of the deep
scp-3700-1 is an arthropod bearing an
aesthetic resemblance to the European
Lobster only much much bigger measuring
six kilometers in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton that bear the appearance of
a woman's face it has six prehensile
limbs four of which terminate in Claws
and eight legs the entity's four eyes
are compound and orange attached to
stalks anyone who gets close enough to
observe the creature's carapace in
detail will notice scars cracks and
small holes indicating years and years
of damage scp-3700
1 has several anomalous qualities in
addition to its size in a fight it is
able to strike with its appendages and
produce cavitation bubbles with a force
greater than several tons of Dynamite
two of the entity's eyes are capable of
blasting concentrated gamma radiation at
a chosen Target the creature has the
ability to impact the weather around it
dispersing storms that impede its
ability to move with ease and can reach
speeds up to 100 kilometers an hour in
spite of its immense power
scp-3700-1 is not aggressive and tends
to ignore beings in its vicinity other
than
scp-3700-2 speaking of
scp-3700-2 it is a 32 kilometer long
entity resembling a pelican eel in all
aspects except for its massive size and
the 13 appendages that encircle the
middle section of its body these
appendages which tuck inside its body
body when not in use are similar to the
tentacles of an octopus complete with
suckers the majority of the entity's
body consists of a sinewy tail
terminating in a sharp point when its
mouth is open it is an estimated three
kilometer steam its flesh is black and
it has white purple and red
bioluminescent lines in the shape of a
man's face on either side of its torso
scp-3700-2's anomalous properties
include the ability to invoke storms
with a severity of category 5 hurricanes
and the ability to produce whirlpools
that draw in any vessel within 150
meters so that it can rip them apart it
is also able to produce high-energy
sound waves as well as blue fire which
it emits from its esophagus when the two
entities interact it results in an epic
struggle as each begins attempts to
destroy or subdue the other when one is
Victorious immediate changes the area
follow when
scp-3700-1 wins the storms and harsh
weather in the area will immediately
calm and an era of fertility and
abundance will begin the reproductive
rates of fauna in the ocean and on the
Islands nearby increase threefold and
the crop yield doubles the ocean itself
becomes increasingly active and the
erosion rates of the archipelago Shores
increase five-fold when
scp-3700-2 wins however the weather
conditions become dangerous with raging
hurricanes rapidly fluctuating
temperatures and constantly changing
Storm fronts that cause destruction of
buildings and loss of life naturally
this renders any Ocean Travel in the
area extremely difficult or even
impossible aquatic food sources are
driven Away by harsh conditions the
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds waterlogged soil and lack
of sunlight all the while
scp-3700-2 swims throughout the area
preying on unsuspecting ships and
menacing the coastline until
scp-3700-1 manifests to challenge it
again
scp-3700-2 will also regurgitate
instances of
scp-3456 though how or why this is
possible is unknown for those unfamiliar
with
scp-3456 they are a group of hairless
three-toed horse-like creatures with
thick translucent skin and human torsos
fuse to their backs they are most
frequently seen near sites of War
terrorist attacks and devastating
natural disasters direct observation of
one of these entities will draw their
attention to the Observer who the entity
will then stalk and capture before
disappearing due to their enormous size
and ability to anomalously manifest in
their home Waters
scp-3700-1 and 2 cannot be contained at
a foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about scp-3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific Publications
scp-3700-1 has been implanted with
dunovian Hollow projectors which
disguise it as a pod of humpback whales
if
scp-3700-1 encounters
scp-3700-2 Delta 7 main gauge protocol
winter Maelstrom this consists of
Destroyers deploying harpoon-based
anchors into
scp-3700-2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target The Entity until
scp-3700-1 is able to subdue it if this
does not prove destructive and
scp-3700-2 cannot be contained then the
task force will Implement protocol
tumult at this point Naval and civilian
crafts in the area must be evacuated
trade and Ferry routes to the
archipelagos must be rerouted for at
least six months there will be constant
aerial and Naval engagement with
scp-3700-2 in constant monitoring for
the reappearance of
scp-3700-1 the behavior of scp-3700-1
and
scp-3700-2 is largely very predictable
with one notable exception on March 20th
2017 a pair of SCP foundation-owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Terran arrived at a point between the
orkney Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 meters away from the
ship's anchor points the water began to
emit intense bright rays of light for a
duration of three minutes at this point
scp-3700-1 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
as CP 3700-1 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws still the hole in the clouds
remained allowing a spot of sunshine to
break through
down on the foundation vessels 600
meters ahead the ocean waters began to
rage and froth spraying foam and surf
into the Air
scp-3700-2 Bursts from beneath the
surface its head pointed upward it
continued to rise until the tops of its
tentacles could be seen just above the
water then stopped to bend its torso and
turn its head horizontally its jaw
unhinged exposing Rose upon rows of
serrated teeth the Beast let out a
mighty Roar accompanied by a stream of
blue flame at the site of its rival
scp-3700-1 Dove beneath the surface
disappearing from view the scps mithir
ordered the rest of the vessels to
engage protocol winter Maelstrom Delta 7
scattered out from
scp-3700-1's point of submersion and all
13 destroyers fired their harpoons at
scp-3700-2 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally faith has
enraged the creature and it began to
Roar and wail spinning its lower body
vigorously enough to generate a
Whirlpool the Cruisers opened fire with
a combination of L cannons and
conventional Weaponry in order to
distract The Entity as the Destroyers
pulled their Harpoon lines taught
dragging its head in a continuous Circle
while this was taking place the
battleships got into position and
prepared to fire on the Mather's Mark
three two one fire the first broadside
barrage collided with
scp-3700-2 and it grunted in pain
thrashing back and forth before opening
its mouth and spewing an instance of
scp-3456 into the water as soon as it
hit the water the equine monster began
to cut through at a pace of 50
kilometers an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the scps
selky the selki attempted to retarget
its weapons and prevent the creature
from reaching it but the monster moved
too quick quickly for the cell key to
adjust the sulky was lifted out of the
water by the creature as crew members
desperately clung to the railings and
their Weaponry as the crew cowered and
tried to fend off the creature it'd
reach for them trying to pull them from
the ship while the selki was occupied
scp-3700-2 was able to attack again
blasting another ship with a stream of
blue fire a loud crack rang out from
across the sea as the selkie dropped
back into the water the scp-3456 instant
shrieking in pain
scp-3700-1 burst through the surface
striking the creature with its club-like
limbs each blow emitting another loud
crack the third blow tore the instance
in half sending its human torso
careening through the air and passed the
scps mithir freed from its attack the
selki moved full steam ahead pulling the
Harpoon line taught again and dragging
scp-3700-2 out of its path several silky
crewmen members were thrown overboard
during the struggle and as they
struggled to keep their heads above
water
scp-3700-1 scooped them up placing them
onto the deck of a nearby destroyer and
out of Harm's Way with the crew members
rescued
scp-3700-1 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the constant
barrage of cannon fire on
scp-3700-2 was beginning to take its
toll and the mithr ordered the fleet to
quote brace for the killing blow as if
responding to the Mather's call
scp-3700-1 shot several concentrated
blasts of gamma radiation at its foe
leaving large holes in the creature in
their wake
scp-3700-2 screened flailing so hard
that it snapped the Harpoon lines and
created waves large enough to push the
vessels backward with its Newfound
Freedom
scp-3700-2 impaled scp-3700 1 through
the midsection with its Barbed tip of
its tail lifting it up and out of the
water with the force of the blow
scp-3700-1 desperately tried to free
itself attacking the tail with its
club-like limbs but the fight was in
vain and after a moment all movement
stopped
scp-3700-1 was for at least the duration
of this manifestation dead
scp-3700-2 tossed the corpse into the
water flinging it past Delta 7 where it
crashed into the water and sank down
Into the Depths below at this point
Delta 7 was ordered to initiate protocol
tumult the Delta 7 vessels turned away
from
scp-3700-2 and prepared to evacuate the
area one of the shifts the scps strasony
Beast slowed behind the rest of the
fleet emitting concerning amounts of
smoke before coming to a stop meanwhile
the enraged and then boldened
scp-3700-2 expanded the size of its
whirlpool setting its sights on the
retreating ships and the weakened
strassany Beast the ship tried to flee
but the engines were completely shot and
would not respond the ship was caught in
the whirlpool and pulled against its
will toward
scp-3700-2 as the crew looked on in
helpless dread a tentacle Rose from the
deep wrapping around the vessel and
dragging it toward the entity escaping
maw suddenly
scp-3700-1 exploded from beneath the
surface of the water leaping between the
ship and
scp-3700-2 cutting the tentacle in half
and freeing the strassany beast from its
grip
scp-3700-2 shrieked before closing its
jaws and biting down on
scp-3700-1 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop
scp-3700-2 from continuing to produce
its Whirlpool another tentacle emerged
from the water polling at
scp-3700-1's legs and ripping from its
body but scp-3700-1 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning
scp-3700-2 with its club-like limbs from
inside of its mouth all at once
scp-3700-2's lower jaw was torn out of
place dropping into the water with
scp-3700-1 still inside
scp-3700-2 thrashed futile growing
steadily weaker and weaker it released
one more stream of fire before
collapsing Delta 7 paused The Retreat
watching the scene for any sign of a
winner but after five minutes neither
entity had moved Delta 7 returned to the
site of the battle to investigate and
saw that neither entity was moving and
both appeared to be deceased shortly
after Delta 7 reached the area both
entities disappeared leaving a single
round unidentified object that sank
below the surface whereas CP 3700-1 had
just been the wall clouds overhead had
dispersed leaving standard cumulonimbus
clouds in their place the waters
themselves remain choppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps Mather sent a radio
transmission to command this is Delta 7
to command we read you down to seven
command replied we have a bit of a
situation go ahead down to seven
scp-3700-1 and 2 are both down command
was silent for 10 seconds utterly
baffled by the information please repeat
Delta 7 again the mythlr said
scp-3700-1 and 2 are both down command
ordered the MR2 standby three minutes of
radio silence later communication
resumed as they asked are either
entities effects active ah negative
command is there any trace of either
entity also negative it appears the
anomaly has been neutralized Delta 7 is
to return to base for debrief following
any recovery efforts with their next
steps clear Delta us of an attached the
strassany bees to several tugboats
preparing to pull the vessel to safety
but there was one more surprise waiting
the scps Mather began picking up unusual
levels of gamma radiation as well as a
sonar contact at a depth of three
kilometers they called command
requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes
one minute of Silence followed as the
command arrived at the decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next
five minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the gamma
radiation levels continued to increase
the ocean turbulence also worsened
tossing smaller vessels and nearly
causing them to capsize then all of a
sudden the water stilled and four large
yellow orbs appeared below the surface
approximately 300 meters from Delta 7.
they lingered their there for two
minutes before Vanishing afterward a new
sonar contact was detected five
kilometers deep directly beneath the
task force command we've lost the signal
from the previous contact and are no
longer detecting gamma radiation we're
detecting new contact five kilometers
deep large and metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes we
advise should
scp-3700-2 manifest exploration teams
are to be considered lost and you are to
return to base the consequences of this
incident as well as what else might be
lurking down in the depths beneath
scp-3700 are still unknown the ocean is
a terrifying Place we've all heard the
statistics more than 80 percent of the
ocean remains unexplored that's most of
the water covering the globe completely
unmapped and unobserved by science it's
a scary thought to dwell on realizing
that there's more water than land and on
earth and the sheer expanse of that
water is so large that we've been unable
to fully explore all of it just think
there are places in the ocean that have
never been seen by a human who knows
what's down there if there was ever a
personification of fear of the unknown
the ocean could definitely be it ancient
shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor
unknown sea creatures hiding away from
humanity and the general isolation of
the suffocating dark blue the ocean
swallows its victims with all of these
images that come to mind when thinking
about the vast and mysterious deaths of
the sea and no one is more familiar with
nautical Mysteries than the SCP
Foundation today we'll be taking a look
at scp-5007 the Bass Strait a wave of
oceanic anomalies fit to make any
seasoned sailor shiver and fear the Bass
Strait is an area of ocean dividing
Tasmania and the Australian Mainland
it's also the location of an unusually
high amount of disappearances Sailors
disappearing from their ships fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming
back even civilians disappearing from
the shores that connect to the strait
the foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the strait
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about Subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the Bass Strait and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the strait agent taverner an operative
of the SCP Foundation was vacationing
with his wife Mary and his three young
children the taverner family was simply
enjoying their day when they saw what
looked like balloons in the sky they
were approaching quickly and naturally
the family move closer what happened
next was a whirlwind and those balloons
the family were so interested in Lifted
them up from the ground and carried them
away agent taverner tried to fight back
but there was nothing he could do except
report to the foundation what had
occurred and the organization responded
in full force the foundation's research
discovered that reports of UFOs and
lights in the sky had coincided with
many disappearances in the strait and
that this was a pattern the search for
the four lost taverner family members
had become a large-scale investigation
into unexplained disappearances along
the Bass Strait and within three weeks
it was determined that these patterns
were consistent across the entirety of
The Straits coastal regions some
witnesses were interviewed but the vast
majority of these abduction cases had no
Witnesses whatsoever of the minimal
reports filed the foundation was told
that there were lights in the sky and
that appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the
appearances of balloon one such witness
interviewed was a man by the name of
Alan Stewart a witness who was present
during The Disappearance of former
Australian prime minister Harold Holt
whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bastrate anomalies during the
interview Stewart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stewart and asked
him if he could see the balloons around
the cliff Stewart had no idea what Hope
was talking about but Holt was insistent
on seeing them he swam deeper out into
the ocean saying that they weren't
normal balloons and that there was
someone inside of them Steward and
halt's family called out for him to come
to shore but he wouldn't listen Stewart
tried to rationalize what he saw next
maybe it was the current sweeping halt
away but he couldn't lie to the
foundation interviewer Stewart saw Holt
go further and further out into the
water and suddenly the Prime Minister
turned around he began swimming in the
opposite direction and he was screaming
suddenly Holt was lifted from the sea
and pulled into the air by something
emerging from the clouds the foundation
thanks Stuart for the interview and
continued their investigation two years
later in 1982 Emergency Services
received a large number of calls
pertaining to UFO sightings off the
coast of Norman Bay Victoria the
foundation was quick to respond alerting
task forces and local sites to prepare
for an investigation upon arriving to
the scene they confirmed the existence
of multiple entities that would later be
documented as
scp-5007 they evacuated civilians from
the area and successfully managed to
capture the creature which was later
transported to site-40 for containment
it was a sight to Behold The Entity now
designated
scp-5007-s-1 was a cluster of human
bodies fused between a grouping of black
tentacles of varying length each
tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the buoyancy
of which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the corpses
appear to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of scp-5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered
scp-5007's behavior during abduction
scenarios was documented during the
initial containment event and due to the
foundation's painstaking research a
pattern was established between all
scp-5007 encounters first the victim
would be alone or otherwise vulnerable
in a coastal location
scp-5000 7 haven't shown a preference
for weather be they clear or hostile
Skies but they have localized all their
activity to the Bass Strait in small
coastal towns beaches or boats
scp-5007 will then move towards the
shore stalking the victim before
lowering its tentacles and appendages to
grab the individual snatching them into
the sky an scp-5007 instance can even
abduct multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured as
CP 5007 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where scp-5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
scp-5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the co coastlines and
Waters of the Bass Strait and equipped
to various Marine task forces with
research vessels capable tracking any
instances if they encounter them in 1985
the foundation's research efforts paid
off and several survey teams operating
in the area reported the sighting of an
extremely large
scp-5007 instance heading towards a
coastal town a mobile task force was
sent to track the entity the team
observed The Entity from afar as it
stocked a private fishing boat even from
the distance Foundation Personnel
recognized the likenesses of several
missing persons as faces of the corpses
of scp-5007 the task force Captain had
to remind his team to keep it together
claiming that they were not people but
just parts of the specimen but everyone
secretly knew the truth the fishing
vessel was a private one occupied by a
small family The Entity slowly
approached and quickly pulled a woman
into the air the family panicked and
quickly tried to reach cover for safety
running into the Ship's Cabin The Entity
ran its tentacles along the boat until
it pulled the door open snatching
another two victims the task force was
unable to help them as their mission was
to track the instance to its origin
point it was a horror to watch the task
force implanted a tracking Beacon onto
the entity and quietly followed it out
to sea over the next four hours they
then discovered a large gray Reef with
several shipwrecks dotted across it 13
scp-5007 instances floated over the area
some holding on to the land Reef with
their tentacles The Entity dropped the
abductees from the fishing boat who were
coerced by the entities into diving into
a massive pool of water located in the
center of the reef one by one each
abductee was pulled below the surface by
something lurking in the pool all while
the scp-5007 instances watched disgusted
the task force reported what they
observed to the main site and the reef
would be designated as scp-5007 Dash a
the foundation's analysis of the reef
led to the discovery that The Rock
covering its seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the
wrecked ships and aircraft that washed
across the shore of the reef were
covered with a dark stone The Reef was
teeming with anomalous marine life
including
scp-5007 a red algae that fed upon the
freshly grown Rock Marine worms capable
of levitation spiders that lived in silk
Retreats underneath the water line small
fish and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp which the
foundation had previously documented
sscp 4159 in a separate investigation
scp-5007 often rested their tentacles on
the outcroppings of the reef while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least four thousand
meters water samples taken from the pit
revealed large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant life
preserving qualities when a being was
submerged in the compound they were able
to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in a storm it reads Mosby spied
land ahead and the boys said that their
giant balloons hanging over the island
we are all a feared but there's not we
can do but Beach ourselves and helpful
rescue should I be killed in the crash I
want my mates to give this journal to my
Mary might know I spent my last thinking
only of her the interior of the ship
contained human remains inside but there
were less skeletons than the foundation
would expect for a ship of its size the
location of the rest of the bodies was
unknown another event related to
scp-5007 the foundation documented
involved Frederick valentic a pilot
engaged in a training flight over the
Bass Strait in 1978. valentic's
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an scp-5007 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what I'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this valentix transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the scp-5007 instance attacking the
aircraft and jamming its propellers with
its mass after crashing into the reef it
was believed that valentic and his
aircraft were pulled beneath the surface
of the pit just as the abductees had
been prior the foundation decided to
construct a provisional secure research
facility on the reef they named it site
40 dash
and documented all returns and
departures of scp-5007 they also set up
a series of containment procedures that
resulted in an scp-5007 returning with
its victims 83 percent less often than
before the site's construction but this
was short-lived in 2008 the site logged
over 36 instances returning to the reef
with only two not having any fresh
abductees the instance's origins were
unknown and it was as if they appeared
out of thin air no other monitoring post
had documented their appearance or even
spotted them before they arrived at The
Reef it was years later in 2017 that the
foundation eventually was able to
successfully explore what was deep
inside the pit at the center of the reef
they already knew that there was a large
entity lurking beneath as evidenced by
what happened to the victims of scp-5007
that were later deposited inside the
pool all previous attempts to explore
the pool were met with failure as the
water pressure of the pit stepped caused
all craft to collapse due to Hull damage
this time however they managed to
construct a high-tech submarine labeled
the scps Nautilus which was capable of
diving a maximum of 13 500 meters
underwater they decided that a d-class
Personnel would be trained to man The
submersible and carry out the
exploration the mission was simple the
Nautilus was to dive to the bottom of
the pit and to describe the depth
readings cameras and microphones were
equipped to the vessel due to the depth
remote viewing of the footage was
impossible instead the foundation had to
physically recollect the vessel in order
to view the footage upon recovery some
of the footage suffered data corruption
but what was there shook those who
viewed it to their core the footage
showed the d-classes experience going
deeper inside the pit at first it seemed
ordinary the trench had a number of
Rocky outcroppings dotted with black
yellow Vines growing along the walls
also present were various marine life
forms such as the spiders or the fish
going deep paper the sub observed an
scp-5007 instance clinging to an
outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the Pit's depths were wrapped
around the instance and holding on to
the entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16
scp-5007 instances were seen resting
along the walls each clinging to the
outcropping as the sub went deeper the
d-class remarked that there were dozens
of plane and shipwrecks but also well
over a hundred
scp-5007 entities most of them were held
there by the black tendrils the d-class
as the sub went even deeper began
noticing human remains no short amount
of them either deep into the pit there
was a large mass of human remains
covering the entirety of the pit bodies
crushed and drained of blood but still
possessing intact eyes each individual
was still alive kept preserved by the
life-sustaining compounds found within
the water the body stared at the sub and
moved attempting to grab onto the
vehicle the d-class swore they were
trying to say something mouthing words
to the camera of the sub as the sub
passed through the mass of bodies it
emerged into a completely dark black
clearing at the bottom of the pit for a
second the d-class thought he was safe
but then a large black tentacle rapidly
emerged from below and grabbed onto the
Nautilus dragging it even further Into
the Depths the d-class screamed and
panicked but there was nothing he could
do the tentacle possessed a large
cluster of eyes mouths and human heads
seemingly grafted onto its mass and then
there was another tentacle and then
another the Nautilus was pulled to the
bottom of the pool the d-class's screams
were still heard even as the picture cut
out sometimes graphic body altering
images of the tentacles features were
visible on the screen but most of the
footage was indecipherable after minutes
of distorted corrupted footage the
Nautilus was seen again rapidly
ascending to the surface somehow it had
managed to escape the entity at the
bottom of the pit upon recovery of The
Craft it was found that the Nautilus was
covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the
d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempted to
harm Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was
short-lived after the containment seal
was fitted sight 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some Personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across lost their body the entirety of
site 40-r went offline and the
foundation could not establish contact
in an emergency effort to do so mobile
task force gamma-6 deep feeders was sent
to investigate the task Force's assault
on site-40-r was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the site's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the Bass Strait
never knowing what their next move might
be and always keeping in mind the risk
that comes with dealing with these
poorly understood entities the divers
scream A Silent Scream as the giant
Squid's beak digs into its skin its many
grasping tentacles grabbing him and
holding him in place nearby his fellow
divers are driven half mad with Terror
as they see mysterious figures floating
towards them through the Merc and
strange Russian voices speaking in their
heads nobody can help them they're down
too deep too consumed by the darkness
and the pressure of the sea they're now
at the mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage What followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into to the cold reaches of
outer space deploying the satellite
Sputnik the United States responded with
the founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962. as United States
citizens feared they were teetering on
the brink of nuclear war in July of 1968
the Soviet Union the United Kingdom and
the United States came together to sign
the treaty on the non-proliferation of
nuclear weapons agreeing to abandon
their pursuit of increasing nuclear
power and turn their focus to
disarmament but several months before
the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as
scp-741
scp-741 is the underwater wreckage of a
Soviet submarine that sank in March of
1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999
the submarine a version of the Charlie 2
class was deployed under unusual
circumstances which attracted the
attention of the United States
government in an attempt to learn more
about the submarine the US government
launched project redacted which
attempted to recover the vessel from the
ocean in the early 1970s they managed to
recover a few pieces of the vessel
though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible Euclid or
ketterclass anomaly in the wreck at this
point it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hull was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seemed to have left something
behind whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices and incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described an incident report
1741-a divers a26 through a30 embarked
from the Icebreaker yamal into the
waters below with the intention of
studying the potential anomalous
activity surrounding the wreckage as the
group of divers approached this
submarine they could feel the shift in
the water around them the oppressive
feeling of abnormally increasing
pressure bearing down and threatening to
crush them if their specialized diving
equipment were to fail they knew that
that would be it and the command would
have to come and fish their corpses out
of the water or even worse they would
vanish entirely meeting the same
mysterious fate as the crew of that
doomed submarine but they couldn't
fixate on that they had a job to do at
first glance the wreckage appeared
undisturbed unchanged since the previous
inspection still they needed to take a
closer look to be sure as the team got
closer to the vessel a30 was startled by
the site of movement from within the
wreckage spotting motion through one of
the holes in the structure as something
passed by he pointed it out to his
colleagues but they dismissed it as
likely a giant isopod or spider crab
which were crawling all over the
surrounding area a30 laughed off his
jumpiness agreed that they were probably
right and continued the exploration as
planned control authorized the divers to
proceed to the next step and a29
activated sonar and lights moving toward
the starboard side breach there a faint
glowing caught his eye the glow
resembled that of radioactive material
but when the team checked the radiation
levels in the area they remained stable
whatever the source of the glow was it
wasn't radioactive at this point his
Neutron counter began to register
something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
can you hear me the voice was muffled
and though could be heard over their
communication channels it emanated from
somewhere in the wreckage deep deep
underwater as a29 watched a glowing
shape emerged from the darkness it was
only an outline the suggestion of a
silhouette but the shape was undeniably
familiar it looked like a person the
other divers quickly noted the operation
and two and began to panic some checked
their nitrogen levels believing it to be
some sort of nitrogen Narcosis While
others pointed out that they couldn't
all be suffering from nitrogen Narcosis
at the same time the unknown voice
continued speaking saying if me it is
getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of uneventful work
another Interruption presented itself in
the form of a five meter long squid
swimming around the wreckage its
presence startled the divers at first
particularly those closest to the animal
but the others encouraged them to ignore
it citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squids circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible in order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a third already saw something else
moving in the depths he couldn't make
out what it was but the side of it gave
him a sick feeling of dread deep in the
pit of his stomach the four divers were
recovered alive along with the shell
examination of the shell indicated that
it resembled that of the extinct
orthoconic nautiloids but it was not
fossilized it was taken for further
study given the possible implication of
extinct species anomalously manifesting
in the vicinity of scp-714 diver a26
lost a limb and was exposed to an
unknown Venom via bites from the
attacking squid his camera was destroyed
in the process a squid are not known to
attack humans unprovoked this Behavior
has been attributed to the influence of
scp-741 though the exact link between
the two is yet to be determined an
anomalous pressure gradient surrounds
the wreck with a radius of approximately
250 meters starting around the center of
the submarine the pressure in this area
is much greater than it should be given
the depth of the water there this
unusually high pressure makes sonar
analysis extremely difficult as well as
threatening the safety of any divers in
the vicinity of the rack the few records
that the foundation has managed to
obtain from the Russian and U.S
governments indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basisti was patrolling the area
around scp-741 when its sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching scp-741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basisti attempted to reach the contact
via sonobui drops and active sonar pings
but it did not respond when the contact
crossed into the total underwater
exclusion Zone it became classified as
hostile at that point the sonar recorded
sounds of an underseen missile launch
and vasisti responded with the utmost
urgency the ship broke away from its
original area and fired a type 53
torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the basisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 meters
and a velocity of 0.92 Mach the missiles
did not emit any detectable radar nor
did they respond to any launch chaff or
flares from the basisti both of the
missiles were engaged by basisti's 3kn5
kinsol surface-to-air missiles and
cashdan point defense systems and were
destroyed at 1800 meters and 210 meters
from Impact respectively after the
missiles were neutralized the Hostile
vessel could be heard engaging in
evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward scp-7 41 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident
1741-c the sonar recordings from the
scps basisti during incident
1741-c were taken for further analysis
by the research team the in-depth review
revealed anomalous acoustic signatures
that did not match up with any known
forms of propulsion including
magnetohydrodynamic drive currently the
nature of the unidentified attacker
remains a mystery and it has not been
attributed to any particular government
or organization following the incident
involving the scps basisti an American
intelligence agent reached out to the
foundation offering further insight into
the secretive government programs
looking into
scp-741 he agreed to sit for an
interview you with a foundation
researcher assigned to the project on
the condition that his identity remained
protected the SCP researcher's name is
absent from the official file as well
the two men sat in the foundation
interview room and the interviewer asked
his informant why he chose to come
forward given the U.S government had
simply chosen to sit on this information
for 30 years you've seen those reports
project redacted now we know that part
too now the directors didn't make the
connection is beyond me that and the
stuff that redacted pulled up yeah the
other part you don't hear about is what
some of the research team died of the
crewmen We buried
Just Uniforms also the nuclear device we
recovered wasn't a missile or torpedo
Warhead it was a demolition charge does
that make any sense after all those
Clues I had to come forward by the
director and didn't it's something I
can't fully explain this particular
statement puzzled the foundation
researcher raising questions he hadn't
anticipated only uniforms did this mean
that the sub had been unmanned the
informant replied no no not unmanned
there were no bodies but personal
effects were everywhere along with
uniforms there was some blood human
before you ask on one of the Torpedoes
in a bit of skin where somebody probably
crushed his hand load in the thing just
no bodies left when I first looked into
all this I had no clue what the hell had
gone on down there but I started putting
things together the foundation agent
began to speculate based on the mounting
evidence could it have been a Soviet
weapons program a deadly biological
agent of some kind no no it wasn't that
I thought maybe it could have been so I
dialed up some of my contacts at vile
preparent a spies wind up owning each
other favors after a while and they
denied it vehemently not your usual
cover-up baloney either they clearly
stated that whatever the sub was
carrying it wasn't theirs they wanted no
part of it sounded like he was gonna
puke when I mentioned redacted doctor do
you have any idea what it takes to make
a bioweapons researcher sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the U.S of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors that they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too loaning you
half the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that scp-741 must be kept
under strict containment procedures due
to the object's location at the bottom
of the sea as well as the unusually
elevated pressure around it it is
unlikely that many civilians will come
into contact with it however as an extra
protective measure sonar and submersible
monitoring is conducted on a periodic
basis in order to verify that the
wreckage has not been interfered with in
any way the foundation contracted
Russian warships as CPS basisti and
krasno yarsk has been selected for this
purpose if any unauthorized activity
occurs in the area surrounding scp-741
nuclear and conventional missiles may be
deployed any movement of scp-741 is
grounds for an immediate Nuclear Strike
whatever Secrets as CP 741 holds
whatever it was transporting that was
even more of an uncontrollable threat
than nuclear warfare they're better left
alone down there at the bottom of the
sea violent chaos unfolds across the
shoreline huge fleshy tendrils Slither
out of the water grabbing people who try
to flee and drag them into the depths as
giant harpoons made of bone whiz across
the beach cutting down unfortunate
sunbathers and droves it is a terrifying
Massacre but you'd never in a million
years be able to guess its source on
April 10 2010 something strange began to
happen in the three Portlands now the
anomalous extra-dimensional city-state
that overlaps with the locations of
Portland Oregon Portland Maine and the
Isle of Portland is no stranger to
unusual occurrences so it took the
population a little while to notice that
something was happening but for some
unknown reason sailboats and motorboats
were beginning to vanish from the city
the disappearances occurred overnight
when there was no one around to witness
them but slowly the citizens began to
notice that their friends and family
members were going out in their
watercrafts and never returning home by
April 15th the civilians were becoming
noticeably concerned fearing the worst
on April 16th their worst fears were
confirmed when two local coasts on
karachnid and Greg Moore went for a
nighttime stroll along the harbor they
heard a sudden commotion and rushed to
the scene of the disturbance they
arrived just in time to see a living
individual being dragged into the watery
depths by a large vein-like tendril
Ahmed asked Greg to wait on land while
he ventured out into the water to look
for the victim unfortunately Ahmed came
back and Greg took his story to the
three Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local
man-eating clam populace to migrate the
FBI unusual incidence unit mounted a
formal investigation on the morning of
April 17th all the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
what not been returned along with them
on April 19th uiu agents dove into the
harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual on April 21st
the threat that had been preying on the
citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 11 19 a.m 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes growing thick
masses of scales on their surfaces
sprouting Harpoon guns that fired bony
projectiles and slashing veiny tendrils
at anyone within reach the citizens
began to panic running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the
Monstrous boats but they were too slow
to evade the attacks and the boat
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of fleshy boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to dry itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert izat
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach izat a city-security Golem
interfered sadly though the Golem put up
a valiant fight the anomaly was able to
destroy it by Falling onto it again and
again until the gollum was no longer
able to get back up there are few
creatures that would survive having a
boat drop itself on top of them
repeatedly and sadly the security Gollum
was not one of them with the Golem out
of the way the boat continued to drag
itself through the streets wildly
crashing through the side of a local
restaurant where its owner an entity
known as the gruel was in the middle of
a busy brunch service at the site of the
invading watercraft the gruel set down
his picture of bottomless Moses wiped
his hands on his apron and grabbed his
trusty dual-wheeled swords from
underneath the counter he kept them
there in case someone attempted to dine
and dash but he figured they would do
just fine against a blood-drinking
tugboat while the gruel kept the tugboat
busy uiu forces were able to break
through the barricade of boats for a
brief period of time allowing more
security Golems to enter the area as
well as allowing more citizens to escape
unfortunately this little victory was
short-lived as further unforeseen
Horrors dredged themselves up from the
deep the reanimated corpses of various
species native to the harbor began to
crawl out of the water surrounding the
gruel and allowing the tugboat to escape
the fight as it made its way back to the
harbor every boat it passed attempted to
toss bodies onto the tugboat covering it
in fresh blood slowly but surely the
damage to the tugboat began to repair
itself once the boat had regained its
strength it set its sights on a previous
untouched cargo ship and observing uiu
officer determined that the boat was
somehow attempting to convert the cargo
ship to transform it into another one of
its fleshy allies but before the
transformation could take place a cargo
crate broke open spilling over 1 000
hardtack crackers suddenly the tugboat
stopped everything that it was doing it
took one tendril and began to count each
individual cracker that had Spilled Out
well the tugboat was distracted with its
task a citizen offered the uiu use of
their rare Metals Cannonball collection
in the fight to apprehend the aggressive
boat one particular Cannonball made from
electrum was able to puncture the whole
of one of the infected ships rendering
it motionless they were related to have
found a weapon that worked against these
boats while the tugboat continued to
count the remaining townspeople gathered
all of the electrum they could find and
began to fight back against the boats
One By One The Boat sank and all all the
while the tugboat continued to count in
the meantime uiu officers managed to
free the gruel from his zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wield like a
bowling ball then the gruel had a score
to settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the girl barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the
girl then threw the tugboat out of the
water and continued The Savage beating
before preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all he lifted it up
into the air jumped up to follow it and
hit it with so much force that the
tugboat kareemed through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the Isle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beating
from the gruel and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there was contained and
given the designation of
scp-6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat
scp-6426 is a ketter-class Sapient
hostile entity that in an inactive State
Bears the appearance of a harbor Tugboat
in a constant state of rust and
degradation any blood or organs
containing blood that come into contact
with the boat will be absorbed through
the metal causing the degradation to
visibly improve as a result the most
effective blood appears to come from
humans cetaceans and a few specific
species of solaceans The Entity does not
only use the absorbed blood to improve
its appearance but is also capable of
using it to create organic additions to
its body including the vein-like
tendrils spotted in the three Portlands
Cognito hazardous eyes attached to
bending eye stalks Harpoon guns and
cannons capable of firing ammunition
made from anomalous species of barnacles
these Barnacles are capable of
reanimating dead tissue on contact and
scp-6426 frequently uses them to create
instances of
scp-6426-c masses of reanimated tissue
that the boat uses to Aid in its attacks
or self-defense
scp-6426 uses its tendrils to grab prey
and drag them towards itself but the
tendrils serve an additional purpose as
well each of the tendrils has a mouth on
the tip similar in structure to that of
the North American medicinal leech when
the tendril has made contact with its
prey the mouth will then bite into the
spinal column of the creature causing
its brain function to cease as its
canines grow long and Hollow hard scales
form on their skin and their muscle mass
and bone density increase once they've
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by scp-6426 are designated
scp-6426-a these instances are used to
the entity's advantage helping it to
extract blood from victims at a distance
as well as providing an additional line
of defense and offense in the event that
scp-6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use
scp-6426-a to convert the vehicle into
an instance of
scp-6426-b these converted boats are
similar to
scp-6426 and are able to function on
their own however they are unable to
produce their own eye stocks or cannons
unable to create
scp-6426-a instances and do not appear
to be as intelligent as their creator in
the the early days of its containment
the exact nature of the anomaly's
intelligence was the subject of debate
amongst the research staff however on
one specific occasion the foundation was
able to establish a line of direct
communication with
scp-6426 and conduct the first and so
far the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and use the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that
scp-6426 responded to interview
questions using the voice of one of its
victims Junior researcher sajad
Williamson in spite of his protest tests
was selected to conduct the interview
his fellow staff members refused to take
no for an answer and as the newest hire
the unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the anomaly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
the self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch sharks selections yes
right
how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's first
question concerned
scp-6426 apparent intended victim back
in three Portlands Albert izat
scp-6426 responded Albert his first name
is really Albert
well what other relationship is there to
say besides the Hunter and the hunted
Admiral is a ruthless Man known for
terrorizing and slaughtering people like
me he was leading a search party of
those barbaric notophiles intending to
gut me like a seal what do you mean
people like you Dr Williamson inquired
free thinkers of course people who are
unafraid to break from the mold to carve
their own path in life instead of
following the predetermined route set by
that ignorant check valve the church is
built upon the foundation of lies no
one's really a petty officer on this
ship we're all just cabin boys stumbling
around in the dark as we followed the
commands of an off-hand cob
if you want real power real Freedom all
you have to do is listen for the call of
the Beast open the porthole and he'll
squeeze you right through
Dr William Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
could you locate your activities within
the harbor and how you arrived there
well after I got the Botswana off my
trail I found a cave to hide him I was
forced to hide them yes forced to hide
deep in the cave which turned out to be
a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel led to
some Coastal Community where I took
Refuge licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as those zealots stuck the
surface I spent my time preparing
Gathering the strength necessary to face
them once more until I was ambushed
assaulted within my Hideout by a
Botswana I fought for my life as I was
forced out into the open and descended
upon by a manner of monsters and freaks
of this orchestrated by that scumbag
ESAT I was beaten within an inch of my
life before I'm not quite sure what
happened after that I believe I was
knocked unconscious you'll have to
Illuminate Me on how I came to be in
your custody at this point the interview
began to veer in an odd Direction the
boat expressed confusion about the
nature of Williamson's questions
specifically how little they related to
the subject of sharks and punching them
it was at this point that the site
director sought guidance from the
multi-u Department a researcher there
informed Williamson about the confusion
scp-6426 had mistaken the SCP Foundation
for another organization the shark
punching Center Dr Williamson resumed
the interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and contain
I mean Solutions this verbal misstep
caused scp-6426 to become suspicious
after a moment it pieced together the
truth and began to throw itself against
the wall in a desperate attempt to
escape it was apprehended by security
guards who impaled it with a naval RAM
and returned the watercraft to its
containment cell the exact reason for
its apparent fear and hatred of the
foundation is currently unknown and the
boat has made no attempt to speak since
currently
scp-6426 is kept in a 39 meter by 39
meter by 50 meter containment chamber
beneath the chamber there is an
artificial lava tube the tugboat has a
naval Ram through its Hull and engine
holding it in place this Ram is checked
daily for signs of degradation as it is
the primary force keeping the anomaly
immobile if the ram is ever removed or
damaged somehow a Fail-Safe system will
activate releasing 100 hardtack crackers
and two pieces of electrum into the
containment chamber this is intended to
keep the tugboat occupied until the
naval Rod can be replaced if for some
reason the naval Rod fails and the boat
runs out of hardtack to count while
there will be nowhere on water or land
that we can hide now go check out
scp-1861 the crew of the HMS
wintershimer and
scp-4217 contained the Bismarck for more